anh alo
anh alo alo
Chúc mọi người nghe điều gì âm nhạc alo
anh alo các bạn rõ
anh alo alo alo
à à
anh
alo alo các bạn nghe rõ không nhỉ
Xin chào các bạn ạ
ừ ừ
Ừ tối hôm trước à ok
anh alo hết hết cỡ đấy tao hay cỡ đấy
các bạn nghe rõ rồi mà
I tr sẽ kéo nhầm mà bù lại thì nó sẽ
ngại Tết
ở bên ngoài có tiếng gì cả nghe được hết
con
gà 8 giờ mình bắt đầu học nhé
anh Minh K là mấy hôm nay khá bận là
cũng như là bây giờ công nhận dạy một
tuần 3 buổi nha
ở chỗ ở
khi mở nhạc cụ bật kiểu gì thế
À
hôm trước hôm trước còn chưa có thời
gian để mà tổng hợp tại các câu hỏi mà
các bạn bình luận ở trên cái chat mới
chỉ mới mới xem lại mình giao và mà chị
khi tổng hợp được hỏi hai câu thôi nghe
cha để buổi buổi sau mình Tổng hợp một
cả hai
khi cả hai các câu hỏi cả hôm nay và hôm
trước
Ừ Thì
có thể thao là nếu thời đi hôm nay sẽ có
nhiều thời gian nhiều thời gian để học
khoa học hơn nữa
À hôm nay mình cũng định là cho các bạn
sẽ học khó ngoại
về Zuma
Ừ nhưng mình thấy đấy à
Ừ để mình nghĩa sẽ học cái cái cơ bản
trước khi mà có một bản trước sau đó đi
mới nhiều bạn
Ừ cái này ở tù mà Thì tùy cách dạy của
nhiều người
vì thế nó qua một chút tại các bạn mới
học là trì các bạn phải sai mấy cái lỗi
chính tả ngay được không biết các bạn có
[âm nhạc]
áo có cổ tích hay không nhưng mà chúng
ta không tốt nhưng mà có tâm từ web hàng
web như thế này bởi vì trông nó hơi soạn
cả một tí
ở Trung Hoa cái
này là mình nghĩ à
nghe tiếng Anh là tiếng anh rất ở cơ bản
đấy thì nên các bạn hạn chế sai bởi nhìn
nó hơi bị ngứa mắt
có thể dùng từ mắt khởi nghiệp nhiều ông
sẽ là kỳ thi ông nào mà sử dụng web
thành web này
à à
em đi chơi chúng thủ
Ừ ừ thật ra là à
anh đưa Hà Nội bớt dán cách rồi đúng
không gọi là đi lại không cần giấy không
thống hàng này cũng như là đi mua đồ ăn
được đi cắt tóc được mà Nhưng mà nhớ thì
tóc thì bạn chỉ nhà chị sẽ cắt cho Bơ
biến hình kiểu đầu qua mất rồi con cái
cắt nữa
à mà chính mình cử đầu cu ơi kiểu cho ta
đổ kiểu như đội cái bát lên đầu nó cắt
anh ra lại không dám ra ngoài đường nữa
ừ
à à
em
còn về đồ ăn thì cứ gọi ship về thôi tôi
ca Lâu lắm rồi mình không ra ngoài đường
ấy
Ừ mình kéo họ Ý mình là dân có nghệ
nhưng mình lại hợp ngoại kiều cả Thế
nhưng không hướng nội
cha mẹ ngay trong khu tin đơn như không
phải mình mình không nằm trong trái tim
thì đều là hướng nội địa hình như anh
Mạnh Tuấn hay là cái Thảo hay là anh
tránh các thứ mấy người đấy hướng nội
cực với người ấy kiểu ở trong nhà mấy
tháng được không tiếp xúc lại được
ở chỗ nói chuyện qua mạng rồi chồng làm
mấy người đấy Xuống nào lắm
không phải sống ảo nó kiểu lúc nào đăng
đăng các thứ sống mà là chuyến dàn mà
đối với họ thì thế giới trên này nó thế
giới cậu mà họ cạnh nhiều thời gian hơn
thế giới thực Ừ cái hội toàn bộ thú vui
thì hầu như toàn chủ yếu trên này chứ
không phải thế giới thức thì thế nên
mình muốn được anh gọi trêu xuống nào
thì à
có mấy người đấy Cần Giờ mày cái nón
dịch này thì cạnh tranh hợp gì cũng như
ta là bệnh mình người ta cũng
ở cửa nhà rồi chụp cái ghế
à à
ba lần ở đây được ra là mình cũng cảm
thấy là
trái thích được không khí nữa kiểu
cho
mấy tuần trước bị mất con mèo
à Mình mình đang bây giờ đang chọn thời
gian tâm sự mà chắc mình tâm sự cũng vài
cái
yên tâm vẫn có tí liên quan đến cài
Ừ cái minh định nói là dân công nghệ sẽ
thế nào khi nghiên tâm mình không đọc đề
gì sao quà đâu
thì mình bị mất con mèo
khi bé lý do mà mình cư sáng và chiều
Khi mà mình lại mở cửa ra ngoài ra ngoài
ra ngoài đường
i10 hít thở không khí một tí vừa đi tìm
em đấy
mà đợt vừa rồi dịch mà thành ra kiểu tới
hạn trời ra ngoài
Ừ nhưng mà kiểu mình vẫn đi tìm mèo trợ
xung quanh xung quanh thôi thì ở thì đấy
cũng là một cái kiểu là Tí nữa mình vậy
đã hơn 2 tuần liền Cứ tập gần như tập
thể dục đấy
ra ngoài ngắm đường phố
rồi đi lại hít thở chung thứ rồi chui
vào chứ ở nhà
Ê con mèo nhà mình là kêu rồi
khi nó chui được qua cái lỗ cửa
ở lại trường để một cái bấc
lỗ lỗ thì ra lỗ cửa khóa
từ
cái bớt đấy khiến cho mình
anh Bình đi tìm suốt hai tuần liền
bộ phim
những kẻ IP đa số hướng nội thực tế nó
như thế nào nhỉ Đôi khi phải nói người
lại đúng đó là hướng nội thừa mới rất
giỏi vì công nghệ tin hay rất giỏi về
những cái thứ liên quan đến những cái
công việc mà phải chỉ tốn thời gian để
mấy mò để tìm hiểu cái này nói chuẩn là
như thế
Ừ mình đi được ca là mình cảm thấy chính
vì cái điều đấy Ờ khiến cho mình sẽ
không bằng được nhiều ông hướng nội
nhiều thế cho mình hướng ngoại với các
bạn thì mình dẫn Đôi khi mình vẫn ham
chơi ở ngoại đôi khi còn bị ảnh hưởng
bởi một cảm xúc nữa nghĩa là đôi khi có
những kẻ thù như chỗ quả bất to quá làm
cho mình kiểu cả hai phía cả tuần cả
tuần luôn mệt mỏi và kiểu chán à các thứ
xu hướng ngoại là cần giao tiếp với bên
ngoài để mà kiểu cầu gần như là đền mà
lấy rồi Gọi
Hà Nội Dùng từ Ở nghĩa là nạp năng lượng
Ừ từ những người xung quanh và thở ra
đôi khi cũng bị ảnh hưởng với những cái
năng lượng tiêu cực của những người xung
quanh
à còn hướng nội thì bản thân họ khi ông
một mình thì họ đã tự tự tiếp cho mình
năng lượng thế này ra là những người
hướng nội theo ngành này thực ra lại còn
ổn hơn những người hướng ngoại khá nhiều
ừ ừ
À
mà hôm trước là đè nhiều quá đi xin lỗi
hôm trước mặt bé hơi nhiều rồi còn
khi bị video lên tận hai tiếng hôm nay
sẽ cố chứ tầm tiếng vừa rồi là ngon
chắc là tầm 1 tiếng 20 phút tâm đấy
à à Em là con mèo nhà mình mới tài tháng
đấy nó chưa vào vào nồi lẩu được đâu
mình nghĩa là mình chỉ mình mình thì
mong Nó là kiểu
có người là bắt về nuôi Bởi vì thực ra
nhà mình cũng
ở nhà mình kiểu
ngay ngay gần đường kiểu toàn container
mình sợ nó chạy mới chạy ra ngoài nó có
vấn đề gì thôi
à à mới kể chuyện đi được tập đúng không
Ok mày còn thời gian đấy Nhưng mà thực
ra cái đấy là nó liên quan hơi hướng hơi
hướng một tí về cái định hướng đi thực
tập
Vì thế nên là mình
anh không Hôm trước mình định là để cuối
muộn để cho mọi người cùng nghe
hơn là bây giờ nói thì mới chỉ có một
vài người An ấy thì một vài người à
sẽ không nghe được Kiểu cái thế
Anh Trung Thu mọi người đi chơi hết rồi
à
Ừ ừ Thực ra thì nó nên là giống như ở
cậu mình thực ra là
mình à
Ừ mình không hẳn à Thích xem nhiều
livestream kiểu như thế này
Ừ mình không mà con người cậu Cái thẳng
Nga cũng không rảnh rỗi lắm rồi mà ngồi
xem là chim
từ những thực tế là
mình đã từng xem vào từng đợi mắm đầu
tiên à JVevermind bị ảnh hưởng bởi cái
cách nói chuyện của anh ấy khá nhiều hồi
đấy mình một sách ngờ Nhưng mà mình xem
của anh đấy
mình à Học cách - bật
cũng từ từ nghiệp và những cái video của
anh đấy thì anh ấy từng nói là thơ ca là
chửi thề không có gì đó nặng nề đâu Hồi
trước và mình còn chưa từng chửi bậy
mình làm cái thông báo sách mà tô màu
sắc ở một ghim kiểu thế
à à
ừ ừ
em sợ sau đó thì không có mỗi cái Vlog
girl nào tạo ấn tượng mình là vì xem thử
nữa
Ừ nhưng mà gần đây thì mình có xem ma
em à Anh độ PC thơ ca là
Ừ mình cũng không xem livestream được
hàng ngày gửi về các bạn thì nó vẫn
giống như mình rảnh vãi ngồi đợi chờ mà
xem livestream mà không đi làm việc khác
hay đi chơi thì gì đó nó ngon
Ừ nhưng mà mình có sẽ những cái video
ngắn cả anh đấy cũng đã xem rồi nghỉ cho
xem những cái rau nhắn của anh đấy và
thấy anh đây cầu dạng là người có tư duy
người có những cái kiểu kinh nghiệm sống
nói chuyện vẫn là anh
khi Indonesia
anh không biết yêu ra là ai luôn ra là
mình
Ừ mình nửa nạc nửa mỡ một tí vào rồi đó
là chuyện là dân công nghệ Nhưng mà thực
ra nhiều cái trong công nghệ cũng chẳng
càng nốt
Ừ mình hỏng phút thì được là cũng mất
tương đối không Này dạng như là
bỏ mặc xã hội bên ngoài đang như thế nào
nhưng mà mình cũng hắn ở một mức vừa đủ
thành ra nào chẳng có đầy người mình
chẳng biết gì cả nhưng
anh em biết họ là ai luôn
Ừ thì nói bé
em hết cỡ mà hôm nay là
À hôm nay là mới chỉ có cái mic thôi hôm
trước mà anh tuần qua chơi anh đấy cho
mượn à cái cái tai nghe tai nghe lấy
cộng tác hết anh nghe đấy hơn bao củ
liền
Ừ Anh ấy đầu tiên gái mình mua cái mic
bao phủ này thì mà livestream cho anh
bảo là mua thêm cái mic nữa à Mua thêm
về cái nghe nữa để mình nghe rồi giọng
bản thân mình Mình biết thì đăng lời bạn
bé đang nói to vân vân vân và cho nghe
được thì mình đang ghi âm đấy
Ừ thế thế nên là
công nhận là dùng thích thật nhiều mà
ban bang hơi khó khăn thì không Dạ Dạ
Mua làm đồ sợ vãi
là chưa Hôm nay 01 tai nghe nên mình
thực sự mình không biết được là mình
đang nói ờ
em nghe được không Hay vân vân mình chỉ
đang mở hết cỡ gần Mic vậy Mà Mong các
bạn nghe được thôi
Có
ai như là mình để ngược mix đây mới đúng
ai alo nghe rõ hơn chưa
à À thầy hiệu trưởng ra ấy á Không thì
ra mọi khi mình là người lạ thầy hiệu
trưởng sự như ý
cho mình nổi tiếng ở mình nhé thích gạ
gẫm bởi vì mình đôi khi nói chuyện với
thằng đa cấp mà
à À đấy thì thôi cá À cái này cũng na ná
ờ ờ
à à
Anh xin lỗi xin lỗi xin lỗi nãy giờ mình
để ngược mic mình bị quên mất
à à
ẩm thực ra mình từng khuyên sinh viên
mình nó hơi bị sai sai một tí đó mình
thường khuyên sinh viên mình là thử đi
làm đang cấp em ạ
em hỏi thử đi làm ở thử vào mấy cái công
ty đa cấp tại sao
ừ ừ
anh Bởi vì con công ty đa cấp khi ở bạn
vào đấy bạn sẽ
chứ không phải học cách là người mà mình
sẽ phải
anh phải biết là họ lừa người như thế
nào biết cách nói chuyện của họ như thế
nào để thuyết phục được người khác
ở công ty đa cấp tại sao nó lừa được
nhiều người như thế
anh bởi vì nó rất tự tin và nó rất là
giỏi cách nói để mà và nó còn thuyết
phục để bản thân nó là cái sản phẩm của
nó tốt vãi chưởng thì nó mới thuyết phục
người khác
ở tại sao tự nhiên lại phải nói vấn đề
với thuyết phục và tự tin ở đây bởi vì
đôi khi có nhiều bạn mình biết bạn ấy
rất tự tin và tự ti Cực
em
đừng nghĩa tự kiêu quả không tốt nhưng
mà đang mở bạn ấy rất là tự ti thành
thành ra là thi phỏng vấn bạn không thể
hiện được năng lực của bạn đấy mà không
chứng minh được cho những người phỏng
vấn thấy bạn yêu tốt phải tự ti thì ra
bạn đấy đôi khi bỏ lỡ rất nhiều cơ hội
và cách để nói chuyện tự tin hơn thì một
là
em nói chuyện với người khác giới nhiều
Ừ cái đấy là một cách đi nhé bởi vì nói
chuyện người Đúng rồi Ông nói chuyện
chán rồi Thằng kia nó bị một màu ấy
hay là ông phải vào công ty cấp
hình ảnh tụi mình thì mình từng vào 22
Công ty cấp điểm mình chưa lừa được có
ai chỉ có họ lừa được của mình thôi
nhưng mà họ lừa mình chỉ là lừa mình đi
đóng tiền để đi tham gia mới khóa học
chúng mình cũng chưa mua sản phẩm đấy
của họ Nhưng mà mình biết cách nói
chuyện hơn của họ
áo kiểu gõ cách nói chuyện của những
người đa cấp mấy kiểu làm cho mình nào
cũng trở lên hình con người như bây giờ
nói chuyện không nó dễ nghe hơn một tí
anh
không Mình nói về cái vụ khác giới Ở đây
là cốt là để mà cho các bạn cảm thấy có
hơn thú hơn thôi còn bạn thích nói
chuyện với đi lại được Nhưng mà quan
trọng này nói chuyện với rất nhiều thể
loại người kiểu đấy và ám chỉ là có cả
cả giới khác luôn chứ không phải là mỗi
cùng giới với cùng giới nó vẫn về cơ bản
nó vẫn có thể một màu đúng không các bạn
mày có nhìn đa dạng hơn em yêu mình tiếp
xúc rất nhiều người mình quen rất nhiều
người mình không ngại việc đấy Mình quen
ở những để anh từ xăm trổ lưu manh các
thứ nó dụng từ đấy Hơi quái Nhưng đúng
là anh ấy cậu tự nhận những ngày lưu
manh thật đâu thế Mai anh ấy Con nói
chuyện được với mình và còn bảo là đợi
mày là thằng đầu tiên kiểu màu sách mà
to quen vào tao nói chuyện được nhiều
thế
Ừ nhắn cái này hơi lạc chủ đề rồi đúng
không ạ
ờ ờ
em rửa mình trả lời nốt cái câu kia rồi
Rồi bắt đầu dạng nha à em làm gì để bớt
tự ti khi mọi người xung quanh đều giỏi
ạ Ở mình thì mình cảm thấy mình nửa mai
nữa không đó là mai ở theo kiểu là hồi
với đại học đấy Mình học ở lớp
I kiểu nó tâm tầm tương đối các bạn đều
không giỏi xuất sắc nên là mình không tự
ti
A và hồi đấy Mình đi thực tập xong thì
cũng nhận là mình đi thực tập sớm hơn
các bạn nên hành ra là mình kiểu cảm
thấy mình hiểu được nhảy cóc sao các bạn
thế Mình cảm thấy mình ổn rãi chưa hiểu
thế như lúc này biến thành tự kiêu sau
đó thì mình khi mình vào nhóm yootheme
commenti này mình bị choáng ngợp bởi vì
toàn Bánh Giỏi mình cảm thấy lúc đấy
mình chả là cái gì
đấy thì lúc đấy mình mới lại bắt đầu lại
họ tiết
cho mình học hỏi rất nhiều và trong anh
em trong you tim này đúng kiểu là con
nhà người ta hết con thần đồng hết toàn
yêu kiểu lá cấp 3 đã ngồi hack khùng
Toàn hack Tâm
ở những công ty lớn xong rồi ngày ngày
đăng bài hack thậm chí ở không đăng bài
hack bởi vì nó nhiều quá rồi địa hình là
ông anh Mạnh Tuấn 15 năng đang tận khách
Hơn chục á chục là ít đấy
blog của anh đấy là hình như là một năm
anh ấy tâm
you know Tokyo blog này anh đấy hồi năm
2017 vậy anh ấy hack
U15 Đăng thôn trăm bài hack kiểu khách
chán chơi ở mình tin là anh ấy hack
nhiều lỗi anh không thèm đăng bài nữa đi
anh thấy kiểu gì ý
Ừ cái hồi trước cái anh ấy để ở đây theo
năm cơ mình hồi đấy mình đọc bài người
mà 15 hơn trăm bài hát Bây giờ sợ vãi
à mà đưa có nhiều cái Trang không nổi
thì bạn hack được cho vui thôi không mà
không cần phải khoe nó làm gì không ạ
nói chung nhà những cái con đem người ta
đấy thì à
Ừ thì á Khi mình gặp mình cảm thấy mình
nhỏ bé lắm nhưng Ờ mình khó bờ lấy đó tự
ti các bạn chỉ cần đơn giản Giống như
mình thường hay so sánh ấy mình không so
sánh mình với bất kỳ ai cả bởi vì ở hơi
xa tuy anh Tuấn giỏi thế nhưng mà nhưng
mà mình cũng không tự ti rồi anh đấy mà
mình vẫn khẳng định là em hơn anh ở một
vài đĩa các dữ bởi vì mỗi người sẽ có
một thế mạnh riêng nhất là mình cần để
tìm ra mình phải nổi bật được cái đấy
mạng đấy để hình giống như là cứ cho là
anh đấy
anh nói ít
Ừ mình thì nói nhiều chẳng ngã và mình
nói ổn hơn anh đấy vì anh ấy giao tiếp
ít nữa nha anh đấy khả năng giao tiếp
của anh ấy kem hết mình trả lại tiền
thừa kế
ý nghĩa là mình là một thằng nói rất
nhiều Do mình sẽ cố biến nó thành thế
mạnh đấy để mình biến nhiều thành lưu
thì mình sẽ bớt tự ti bé thứ nhất mình
sẽ không tự ti về nhược điểm mình nữa để
cái thứ nhất đóng học thì thứ hai đó là
các bạn ý so sánh với chính bản thân
mình sau quá khứ
ý nghĩa là mình đã tốt hơn sau quá khứ
chưa mình sẽ phấn đấu ngày tốt hơn sau
quá khứ hơn là các bạn đi so sánh có
những người xung quanh
anh Bởi vì các bạn chỉ cần tốt hơn sau
quá khứ rất nhiều bản thân chính bạn sẽ
được khen bởi những người xung quanh
À
mà thôi lạc đề hơi nhiều rồi Ok hôm nay
bắt đầu học thì
ở đầu tiên là bây giờ
qua Thế mày sẽ làm gì nhé
À hôm nay sẽ học về những hàm cơ bản cho
dù hôm trước mình đã
anh hứa
không ăn hứa Nhưng mà đã nói trước là là
sẽ định học
về khoa ngoại nhưng mà mình cảm thấy là
khóa ngoại với kết hợp việc là có thêm
nhiều bạn bây giờ là các bạn sẽ dễ bị
loạn nên là mình nghĩa mình nên Dạy cái
này trước những hàm cơ bản trước liên
quan một bàn trước để những buổi sau chỉ
học về nhiều bạn Sau đó dần dần có cả
hàm này kết hợp với nhiều bạn thì nó sẽ
như thế nào ạ
à à
Ừ đấy thì bây giờ là ổn ôn lại bài hôm
trước này trả lời câu hỏi hôm trước
nhưng mình đã nói được là mấy hôm vừa
rồi mình rất là bận thì cuối tuần nhưng
phải là mình rất bận
ở đâu gồm cả bận chơi và vẫn ngủ bởi vì
lễ cuối tuần mà thông cảm tí là
nên là mình chưa tổng hợp lại toàn bộ
câu hỏi
buổi này chuyên hôm trước được các bạn
là có thắc mắc gì Các bạn cứ hỏi ở loài
chim nhá các bạn không Thứ đó không có
cái đường link nào bị để bây giờ thì các
bạn đang câu hỏi cả mà các bạn nên bình
luận và trong chính cái livestream này
thì mình tổng hợp lại
à à
à à Thế nên là để buổi sau mình sẽ tổng
hợp cả buổi livestream bấm trước còn hôm
nay chắc chỉ mới có một mình mấy chị
tổng hợp từ hai câu hỏi thôi
mà bài tập buổi trước thì ra rất dài nên
là bây giờ sẽ
cho Bơ sẽ thử ngồi là ngồi chữa đúng
không
a
tiếp theo là hôm nay mình sẽ gặp những
hàm cơ bản những làm cơ bản à
Ừ cái này thì ra là nhắc từ trong chính
cái bài tập thì các bạn sẽ biết được có
những hàm cơ bản như thế nào
Xin chào bạn Bích Ngân Lê Thị
à à
10 Thực ra là
mình thì đương như mình có để lượng Xem
đấy nhưng mà mình không
không chú trọng về số lượng lắm Mình
quan tâm về chất lượng hơn thế mình vào
hai mươi tám mươi mà thực tế là
à mà thực tế là mình vẫn sẽ dạy cho dù
kể cả Ở đây có mỗi hai mấy bạn
Ừ nhưng mà lần gần đây thì mình phải
chia tay câu lạc bộ mình khi mà nó chỉ
còn là bốn bạn hay bà bạn cá thử từ
Ừ
mình chia tay không phải vì còn bốn bạn
là chia tay ở bởi vì à Ở bên này có
nhiều người quan tâm hơn
ý con là bây giờ
anh nói thẳng nó kể cả cho dù mình yêu
về sau chỉ có mỗi 4 loại dậy đương nhiên
là thế lực là sai quá bởi vì có khi là
do cách dạy của mình
gì sai vãi chưởng nên thành ra lượng
người giảm con nít như thế nhưng mà Nếu
giả sử trong một trường hợp nào đó giả
sử là kiểu đấy giả sự hôm nay là mọi
người đi chơi chẳng hạn hãy ra ít người
on này Vân Vân ngoài chỉ có 23 bạn học
thôi thì mình vẫn sẽ định theo cái kênh
này đến cuối bởi vì ạ cái kênh Bây giờ
mình đang quay video lại mà mình quay
video lại trên chính kênh nha YouTube
của mình thì ra đấy rất là hay may may
mà tự nhiên mình lại quay trên này thời
ra cặp đi về mình có hướng vì sau mình
sẽ có kênh YouTube để mà vừa để dạy vừa
để livestream hạn chế đôc kia livestream
khi mình cốt em ạ này mọi người có cái
nhìn thoáng nó giống kiểu với nó đấy
inox của dân cùng với ông đi thì có rất
nhiều Anh chuyên mơ kiểu dân công nghệ
thông tin cốt các thứ thử rồi anh ấy dõi
mình rất nhiều nhưng mà
Ừ đấy là một cái một trong những cái
Minh Tự tin là mình có thể nói chuyện sẽ
tốt hơn anh đấy trả lại Bởi anh đấy Dân
công nghệ hoàn toán mình thì là công dân
nửa mùa nên đôi khi lại lại một điểm Lợi
anh vẫn hơi đi xa vấn đề quá nhỉ thôi
Tại qua lại gần đây nhá
mình mở buổi hôm trước đã Mình lưu bài
tập trên ai
à
mình mình có đang blog đấy nhưng mà blog
của mình thì
nó mang trên hướng là cái suy nghĩ của
mình nhiều hơn là việc là dậy 2 á nó nó
có một tí một vài cánh kiến được chia sẻ
thôi
à à
ở đây
Ê mày bảo không nên bình luận đáp án
tránh gian lận sâu với cùng thì bài này
có 11 người bình luận luôn ạ Không biết
được do các bạn làm bài tập hay chưa Hay
các bạn
Ừ như nào Đấy Như bây giờ còn cái bài
chẳng có ít bình luận nhất mình thấy
mình đầu tiên mình sẽ quay tập hôm trước
đúng không À đây đây Cái này hôm nay có
bạn hỏi mình đó là
từ khi có bạn lưu lại tiếng Việt có dấu
ấy thì các bạn sẽ bị hỏi như thế này thì
các bạn nên chọn cái ấp lythu demonsouls
như thế này thì nó mới lưu tiếng Việt có
dấu lại ở trên này được
à à Có nhiều bạn hỏi mình các thứ về
blog này hè Linh cá thử Linh vận chuyển
Binh kế phát minh cốt của mình thì ra là
Facebook của mình nó công khai hết mọi
thứ các bạn là chắc là chìa khóa chịu
khó qua trang cá nhân của mình minh sẽ
không Mình sẽ không bể Linh cá nhân của
mình trong mấy cái
YouTube hay các thứ vì không phải là
mình
e ngại cái gì cả mà mình cảm thấy à tình
01 bánh bóng tên tuổi làm gì cả nhưng mà
các bạn
biết được mình qua Facebook mà đúng
không thì các bạn thể tìm thấy được mình
có đấy trên đấy mình nha không cần để ẩn
theo dõi mình nó nhá rất nhiều ông theo
dõi tôi thôi với sao Huy chỉ vì thấy tôi
thằng Băng ấy gì người màu hè Đang cái
gì đó Kiểu như anh Tuấn bằng gì hãy hứa
về dân công nghệ thông tin hay là chia
sẻ cái gì Giàu về dân công nghệ thông
tin vân vân vân
tôi là chúng tôi chỉ người bình thường
thôi nên tôi sẽ đăng những cái mà rất là
giản dị
Ừ nhưng mà trên trang cá nhân của mình
thì có có
blog lẫn cả có linh khí thấp các bạn thể
qua theo dõi ở trên đấy nó sẽ ổn hơn
có
link Facebook là gì á thì các bạn tra
Google chưa tin nnl thì các bạn sẽ ra
rất nhiều cái
về mình để mọi nơi đều có một kẻ user
name Và như thế này một cái nickname mà
như thế
300 cái này nó kìa lạc đề nhưng vẫn có
một tí hai đó là mình đã định nói là các
bạn đôi khi các bạn cũng phải nên để ý
cái user name hoặc nickname của mình nếu
bạn muốn trở thành một con người kiểu
dạng là
em không ăn nổi tiếng nhưng mà dễ tìm
kiếm trên Google Kiểu cái thế
à mình để ý cái đấy cực Nó kiểu nó gần
như tên tuổi mình để trao Google theo
cái đấy theo cái từ khóa nickname thì nó
sẽ ra trang Facebook này hè chạm mọi thứ
của các bạn giờ Hay bây giờ có nhiều ông
vẫn còn đang để ở Instagram là kiểu
1 kiểu ví dụ là
sau đó gì à
có link Facebook là một triệu vân vân
vân vân
à
Thành là nó rất là loạn à
Ừ
thôi quay lại gần đi xin lỗi xin lỗi vẫn
dài dòng quá
à à
đầu tiên là tạo bảng sinh viên đúng
không
mã này đi này khi DAMtv tự động tăng à à
à
à à
ừ ừ
ưu điểm lần 1 này à
ưu điểm lần 1 thì à nếu nếu mà các bạn
muốn theo thang điểm trên 10 giống như
mình làm thì đương nhiên là các bạn hoàn
toàn có thể phải kiểu 1 phẩy thận chỉ là
một phải 0,5 này các thứ từ
thì các bạn để flash là Hội An
em không cần phải để kiểu đúng không đến
hai flash ạ
Ê
Mập American mãi
Ừ hình như ở trong bên của mình nó có
bạn sinh viên mất rồi nhưng mình sẽ tạm
giúp thấy bồ hoa cà mình có thể tạo bảng
mới đã tới bây mờ đi là dụng là buổi
4000a
hình ảnh sao mình sẽ yêu buổi 4 đúng
không ạ
Ê mà tao mày mới đúng không để tránh
việc chung với trùng Bảng 2 ngày các thứ
thứ
Vì sao không bỏ file Mickey ở trên đầu
hẹp em Mickey này đúng bạn có bạn hỏi ra
hai tiếng lý do đó là cậu mình
Vì mình thấy ở thời ca các bạn hoàn toàn
để pha Nikki ngay trên này và không cần
thừa dòng như này cũng được nhờ sự ra
thế này ở lại không tốt tại sao không
tốt bởi vì à
Ừ cái này
thì mình nghĩ là mình cưới để câu hỏi
cho các bạn tự
anh
tự tìm hiểu chưa các vừa buổi sau mình
trả lời nhé vì buổi sau mình có nhắc đến
đó các bạn khác nữa nó nối xong bạn khác
nữa thì có bạn sẽ hiểu
đi câu hỏi bạn đấy đúng không Là Tại Sao
không để
không khai báo
và mời Kỳ ngày tại cột đó mà để
ở dưới
bộ trưởng
Em in lpt ở đây là tự động tăng chưa
ờ ờ
ý với điều kiện không điểm không được
phép nhỏ hơn 0 và lớn hơn mười ra các
bạn thể nếu mà chưa chưa in xuất thì cả
thì mình có thể ra đi Đúng không ra đi
Sau đó thì
I am in ghi lại check vào trong này hay
là các bạn à
khi enter cấp 3 nhiều cách đúng không
Đây mình sẽ ghi trách nhé trách này sách
nó độc lập với cột này mình sẽ ghi ở
dưới ấy đầu tiên là trách à
khi cả hai điểm đúng không điểm lần 1
anh lớn hơn không
em điểm lần 1
nhỏ hơn 10 en điểm lần 2
lớn không em điểm lần 2
nhỏ hơn 10 nhớ ai chẳng ạ ạ
ta có
Ừ Ok cái này thì sẽ khiến cho điểm điểm
cả lần 1 lần 2 nó sẽ chỉ nằm trong cái
khoảnh phạm vi này đúng không
có bạn không Trước Và mình thấy có bạn
ghi là điểm
á đông Nhầm điểm lớn hơn bằng đúng nhỉ
Ừ đúng rồi Cái này mình hơi bị nhầm tí
mình tạm giúp đi ạ Cái Thực ra là có bạn
thì làm theo cách này để để cho lớn hơn
bằng 10 được nhưng mà cái này được không
đúng bởi vì a các bạn để flash thì điểm
có thể là 10,5 Thì nó sai
thì các bạn phải để nó lớn hơn bằng nha
Ngắm chuẩn chưa có bạn không nên để nó
là flash rồi kết hợp với điện nhỏ hơn 11
ngay bởi vì ở Nếu thế thì điểm có thể
10,5 đúng không ạ
ưu điểm cho là lớn băng đây Ok Ok này
Mình bị nhầm đó
ê kê ngon Ừ rồi
ở đây một cách thôi các bạn có thể làm
thêm còn ngược lại được là không được
phép hay các thử hướng
Ừ đúng rồi ghi cả nhà đúng này
ưu điểm lần 10 nhập mặc định sẽ là năm
này thì cái này nó là defoe này đúng
không iPhone này để phô liên quan đến
cột này thôi nên nó sẽ ghi kiểu này thì
phố 5 này
lại giúp đi này
em chạy lại ừ các bạn có khi em phải xem
hết xuống dưới này đã thôi xem clip sau
điểm lần 2
anh không được nhập khi mà lần một lớn
hơn hoặc bằng 5
ở câu này có sao Mình nghĩ là mình cứ
tạo quà tạo trước đã rồi mình sẽ ăn tơ
nhé mày câu sau này mình sẽ làm sau này
có tiền là đi sớm đúng không research
into sinh viên này
à à Ừ Nếu mình muốn
khi
họ tên điểm lần 1 mà điểm lần 2
Alo Này là sự là năm đi một là năm này
ở địa lần 2 3 sản Hạ
I Insert các bạn hãy xuất được đúng
không thử xe lách sao form sinh viên để
xem nhé
Ở đây các bạn hãy in-shop thành công
không vấn đề gì cả đúng không
à à Nhưng mà bây giờ giả sử đổi thành âm
ba thật là ý sẽ cảm này nó sẽ lỗi Đúng
không Nó lỗi mà liên quan cái check một
cái chết nào đó Bởi vì à Mình chưa đặt
tên cho cả trách tiến hành ra là mình
mình bị gạo tên Kiểu như này các bạn là
tên nó trách thì các bạn sẽ nó lại sẽ
khai báo là con chết thì phải con sợ trễ
trên là check giới hạn điểm lại
như này
ơi mình tạm rốt nói đi nhé
để tái tạo lại
anh Bởi vì nếu mình không Lúc đi thì
mình phải dốc đúng cái trách em ạ sau đó
mình phải ác lại cái chết mới với cái
con chết tên như thế này chưa mình tạm
ra đi á
ở đó sau đây Insert đó thì các bạn bây
giờ khi mày in sơ mà lỗi Nó sẽ hiển thị
ra đúng cái cách mà khiến cho nó lỗi nó
khiến cho nó không được ý giấc thì ra
đến
ạ Bây giờ là Insert thử bạn 11 điểm đấy
ạ thì chắc chắn vẫn sẽ không được đúng
không Nói tôi sẽ báo lỗi Ok đây ít bạn
làm như này sáng
ở đây là được đúng không Ok tiếp theo
lấy ra bạn điểm lần 1 và lần 2 lần năm
Bây giờ mình gửi cho bạn khác đi lại anh
Toàn đi ngon
Anh
Tuấn điểm
Ở
lần 13 lần 27 ạ
em và bạn nữa
Ừ anh đi
Sáu luôn trận
thời điểm lần thứ hai mình sẽ cho làn
nun nun tức là kiểu để chấm thì chưa các
bạn không để nhập số 0 ở đây được không
ở đây không tính cho chấm mà nun chẳng
qua là không không nhận gì cả mà
khi nhập điểm ví dụ thôi không không có
ý chê hiệu trưởng của chúng ta đâu sau
đó thì các bạn muốn lấy điểm lần 1 hoặc
lần hai đúng không Thì hoặc ở đây sẽ là
ảo mà ngon
ở tennessee success from sinh viên lấy
ơi bạn sinh viên với Word với điểm lần 1
anh lớn hơn 5
a ho điểm Phần 2 lớn hơn năm
có bạn thắc mắc với mình là
Em có cách nào để ghi nhanh hơn loại này
không một vì một trong hai thằng đều lớn
hơn năm ở được mà đúng không có ghi theo
kiểu là điểm lần 1
to điểm lần hai xong rồi trong ngoặc lớn
hơn em nghe được không Cái nè 01 vì
thằng về với ngôn ngữ lập trình thì các
bạn không ghi Cửa phát nghe được quên
Lập trình là không đi tắt được đấy được
các bạn phải ghi rõ là như thế này về
chưa
anh em
khi chạy thử nhỉ
sau đó thì các bạn sẽ thấy là lấy ra
được Anh Tuấn một việc không phải vì
điểm lần 1 mà vì điểm lần hai đúng không
có lấy ra bạn anh Bởi vì điểm lần 1 của
bạn đây đã lớn hơn rồi đúng không
à
à Lấy ra các bạn qua môn ngay từ lần 1
tức là qua môn ở đây các bạn sẽ hiểu là
điểm là một là lớn hơn bằng 5 đúng không
sẽ copy tiếp này
các bạn này thì K nhắn mà không tôi mới
dễ đến bằng 5 thế sau
Ừ nó thì chỉ có mỗi bạn anh này quá muốn
anh tên một đúng không còn anh Tuấn lần
2 nếu mới qua môn đúng không lấy ra các
bạn trượt môn chuyên môn ở đây á Ý mình
hiểu là thi cả là một lần hai đứa chưa
đúng không là lần 1 và lần 2 đều rồi năm
chẳng hạn đúng không
Thì cả đấy chắc là bạn hơn mình rồi nó
mới Mình nhớ không lầm là điểm mình thấy
bạn thì đây à
xe điện là một dưới 5 này
em điểm lần hai cũng dưới 5 này là sự
đấy không
em chạy lại đó thì ra bản thân mình là
cái điểm lần 1 ở điểm lần hai đều rời
năm chưa ạ ở đó tiếp
ạ bây giờ bắt đầu sang cái sao rồi thì
mình nghĩa mình sẽ ưu tiên làm cái trên
trước nhé
ưu điểm lớn hay không được phép nhập Khi
mà điểm lần 1 lớn hơn hoặc bằng 5 tức là
lần 1 khi qua rồi đúng không Thì lần 2
không được nhập nữa ý ý hiểu và như thế
về chưa ạ
Ừ thì các bạn thi lần 1 qua rồi thì các
bạn thi lại làm gì đúng không các bạn
không cần phải thi lại cũng không được
nhập luôn thì bạn chất ở đây tức là mình
sẽ hiểu Dễ hiểu là mình sẽ đầu tiên phải
có 1 cái trách đúng không cách này nó sẽ
là cách này sẽ là
thì đầu tiên mình kiểm tra theo kiểu lại
điểm lần 1
lớn hơn bằng 5
Ừ Thì sao Thì điểm lần 2 không được Nhật
sức cẩn điểm lần hai phải chống đỡ nặng
thôi em điểm lần 2
itneun
cái phải chồng ấy thì các bạn phải bằng
ngu như thế này như thời gà trong trong
SQL nó không có khái niệm bằng nun bởi
vì new là không có giá trị nên là bạn à
anh không thể bằng được mà các bạn phải
so sánh Muốn sai so sánh nền luôn rồi
các bạn phải ít thì chưa
Ừ cái đấy kiểu so sánh
do đó nếu mà chạy như thế này nếu mà chỉ
chạy ngay thôi thì các bạn luôn phải
nhập điểm lần 1 lớn hơn 53 điểm lần hai
luôn chấm Thế lại sang mất rồi đúng
không cái này chị sống trường hợp là
điểm lần 1 lớn hơn bằng năm thì điểm lần
hai chấm còn ngược lại thì sao điểm lần
1 mà nhỏ hơn 5 thìa mình chẳng phải kiểm
tra gì cả đúng không Cũng chẳng cần kiểm
tra gì cả nữa thì mình sẽ có 1 cái mộc
tròn ở đây o điểm lần 1 nhỏ hơn Nam phía
song điểm nổi một nhỏ năm nữa chẳng cần
quan tâm điểm đã thay như nào về chưa
điểm lần 2 mà lớn hơn 52 à hay là có giá
trị hay là chưa có giá trị như cái mình
không trọng chưa
ý Thì cái này nó sẽ ra mình sẽ là tín
hiệu rất là trên này cũng được hoặc cả
mình sẽ enter table sinh viên đúng không
sau đó thì yep còn chết à Mình nhớ không
lầm như thế ai còn chết
ạ sau đó mình button nó nó nó trách
phụ
trách nhiệm điểm đi nhập điểm lần 2 cho
nó hơi dài tí ý
Ừ rồi đúng không Bây giờ giả sử là mình
sẽ đi Shop mình sẽ in shop trong trường
hợp này
để các bạn xem qua luôn để mà biết được
nó có chạy được hay không đúng không
Mình cho bạn cho cũng là Anh Tuấn Anh
Tuấn phiên bản hay ngầu hơn đi anh đấy
cả hai môn Điều 77 chẳng hạn thế đi sợ
này đó bên nó sẽ bỏ lỗi Đúng không
ạ bây giờ thì không thể nhập
ưu điểm là một lớn năm mà điểm lần 2 có
giá trị nữa mình thử nhập luôn ạ ạ thế
bạn sẽ thấy là ổn thôi
À hôm trước của bạn hỏi mình nếu mới trả
sự mà anh thêm cái check này
ạ sau khi mà anh yêu in search
cho ví dụ Giả sử là mình lỡ nhật kể bạn
cái anh Tuấn là điền 77 trước trước khi
mà tạo khoảng cách này mới rồi đúng
không Thì thì có bị Daily không đúng
không cái này thật ra có cái gì à
sau khi mà các bạn tạo check này này nó
lại kiểm tra lại hết tất cả các dữ liệu
trong bảng xem mà có thỏa mãn mình có
trách này không Bởi vì cái chắc này
không phải là mỗi khi các bạn Insert mà
khi các bạn update và kể cả khi mà các
bạn
chị đã có sẵn dữ liệu rồi nó vẫn sẽ kiểm
tra lại hết để xem là cả cái bàn này có
thỏa mãn cái chết hay không thế nên là
khi mà các bạn lỗi in xuất
một sinh viên là kiểu dạng là có hãy
điểm đều lớn hơn năm nay rồi đúng không
thì các bạn không thể tạo được cái check
này nhé các bạn phải xóa sinh viên này
đi hoặc Cập nhật lại điểm sinh viên đấy
cho đúng với cái check thì các bạn mới
tạo được trách gì chưa
hồ bơi không thì mình cứ bảo hả Hả Không
Anh không nghĩ bây giờ mình cấu tạo một
cái check hẳn một con chết sau nhé
em bỏ đoạn o điện à trước khả năng đêm
cái chai này trách điểm
khi cài đặt và sử thế đúng không Mình
chạy thử các bạn xem này nó sẽ bị lỗi
Ừ nó các bạn sẽ thấy nó lỗi nó không tạm
được cái chết này đó hay không vì sao
Bởi vì à
ưu điểm của mình không phải điểm lần một
luôn luôn lớn hơn em là sai rồi nhìn
thấy mẹ sai rồi không cần quan tâm mình
cái bên này nữa chưa Cái bên này Kệ làm
chị là cả hai bên phải đúng rồi nó học
cái bên này chắc chắn sai rồi không có
tâm bên này nữa bên lập trình là như thế
đó là một
ở một đôi khi nó sẽ kiểm tra từ trái
sang phải kẻ trái sai rồi thì nó sẽ
không quan tâm mình với phải nữa
ừ ừ
ở đó để có sao một có sao đúng không
tiếp lại kéo xuống dưới tiếp đếm số bạn
qua Mun sau khi thi lần 2
cái này tức là sao Cái này chỉ đơn giản
đâu là đến số bạn qua môn đấy đúng không
Ừ
thì mình sẽ là xe lách cái đêm ấy thì nó
dùng hàm thứ mà hôm nay mình sẽ học là
hàm cao đã đến các bạn nên biết một
tiếng Anh Tí về cái mấy cái này Đây là
tiếng Anh chuyên ngành các bạn cũng cũng
sẽ sẽ phải nhớ thôi chứ không đồ tại
mình bị mất gốc tiếng Anh các bạn được
hôm sinh viên à que nếu mà nếu mà các
bạn thì chạy ngay thôi nhé thì đây sẽ
đến tất cả sinh viên và bây giờ đang
cũng muốn bạn sinh viên là tiếp theo là
các bạn muốn thêm điều kiện nhưng mà đến
thì que
ưu điểm lần lần 1 đúng không à à
u5o điên lần hai lớn hơn 5 năm
anh không
Ừ thì đây là điểm tất cả bạn đã qua môn
chưa
ở đó thì bây giờ sẽ trả về là ba tất cả
ba Bạn có muốn con bạn muốn hiển thị
chính xác tất cả bạn có muốn thì các bạn
chỉ đơn giản là select sao thay vì cao
thôi đúng không Chị sẽ đi tất cả bạn có
muốn
ở đây
đi đái thế là xong đúng không còn bây
giờ các bạn chỉ một đêm thì nó sẽ như
thế này
Ừ Ok đúng không bà
ạ Sau khi thi lần đó là sợ hình như mình
bị ghi này các bạn hiểu nhầm ý sau khi
khi đi 2 lần đấy ra thế
Ừ ừ thì sau sau khi thi lần 2 nó có
nghĩa là theo theo theo như lúc đầu mình
mình mình hiểu hết
Ừ Thì
anh tặng tên các bạn qua môn thì giống
như mình vừa nói thì mình dùng Surf sao
thay vì dùng cao cao này nó sẽ chỉ đơn
giản là đến thôi nó sẽ không thể hiển
thị ra được danh sách các bạn đã qua môn
đâu nếu mà các bạn muốn kiểu vừa muốn
nếm vừa muốn thì đi với thông tin mà
mình chạy thử các bạn sẽ rõ nó sẽ không
ra bởi vì à mình sẽ không lấy được cái
trường nào khác cái thứ mà hôm nay mình
sẽ học đây
anh vào các bạn sẽ không lấy được các
cột khác
à mà mua khi có bạn dùng những cái hàm
hàng này hàm này à
nghe tiếng Anh nó tiếng Anh nói JK không
hẳn là có những có nghĩa gì nó dễ hiểu
lắm nói cho mà có những cái Hàn mà có
dùng như thế này nó là gặp nhóm nhóm lại
Goodbye mà ngon
Goodbye nhóm lại này
nhóm lại với nhau này
khi những cái hàm kiểu như thế này thì
các bạn sẽ không lấy á không hiển thị ra
lại không hiển thị được Cột nào không
nằm trong luc bài I
Ừ tí mình sẽ giải thích cái cái này nó
hơi khó hiểu tí à
Ồ thông Cái này nhiều bạn cho mình đi để
làm nhiều bạn bị hiểu hơi nhầm một tí tí
à sau chị khi thi hai lần hơn à À thì
hai sau khi thi hai lần Thuận như thế hệ
II
ạ Sau khi thi lần 2 cũng được nếu ý à
à nếu nếu thế thì phải loại bỏ các bạn
đỗ thì lần một đúng không Mình chỉ quan
tâm lần 2 thì nó sẽ như này thôi không
sẽ sẽ này thôi mà nó vẫn không
Ừ nó cũng không sao
ý là có bạn vừa Nếu Ok mình trả lời luôn
cả con này nhé á
lịch
thi lần 2 này sau À đây trượt lần 1 và
qua môn
sau lần hai thằng ạ ý bạn như này đúng
không Ok thì có bạn vừa trả lời đó là
điểm lần 1 nhỏ hơn năm và điểm lần hai
lớn hơn năm như này đầu ngoặc
anh chỉ có hai bạn thử xem hai bạn đấy
là ai nhé
chị xem đúng nha à
ví dụ
ừ ừ
anh không cần em mẹ em mới đúng mi xin
lỗi
ở ngoài có một bạn của bạn bạn Tuấn đúng
không chuyên lần 1 Đỗ lần hai đúng không
Nhưng
à Tối nay thử cái là nó hơi thừa cái hơi
thừa giống như có bạn vừa trả lời từ cái
này hơi thừa Tại sao ạ Mình đã nói thừa
Bởi vì các bạn quên mất cái trách ở đằng
trên cái trách đoàn trên nó đã kiểm tra
Ừ nó là kiểm tra
Ừ nó đã kiểm tra hộ mình là điểm lần hai
luôn Có Khi mà điểm lần 1 nhỏ hơn 5 rồi
nên các bạn chỉ cần bỏ qua như này là
được vẫn sẽ nhận nhiều cái chết không để
chết ở trên này mình đã tạo cái check là
là điểm lần
điểm lần 1 mà
anh lớn hơn năm thì điểm lần hai phải
chấm con điểm lần 1 nhỏ hơn 5 thì thì
điểm lần 2 được nhập đúng không mua khi
ngủ khi điểm lớn hay được nhập thì chắc
chắn sẽ sẽ hoàn toàn là điểm lần 1 nhỏ
nhỏ năm rồi nè các bạn không cần kiểm
tra lại cái vụ đây nữa đâu mua đồ ngoài
đúng
à à có bạn vừa hỏi cái đấy Mình đang
định trả lời đó là nếu mà các bạn chạy
cao như này đúng không cao nhé Thì có
bạn sẽ để ý là nó sẽ không hiểu định tên
cột ở đây nó nấu có luôn nêm và các bạn
muốn thể tên cột thì các bạn sẽ là ác sợ
đây tôi chưa Sau đó thì các bạn để trong
dầu ngày ngay hoặc không cần dầu ngày
cũng được nhưng mà mình thường để trong
dấu ngày theo nó chắc bởi vì các bạn màn
nhập có dấu vào đây được trong giờ mẹ
các bạn Nhập có dấu và dấu cách được
thoải mái là sử ở đây là số bạn chuẩn
lần 1 và qua môn lần 2 và đương nhiên à
Nếu muốn có muốn hiển thị có dấu được
như vậy Hiện bị n đúng không chạy thử
nhé
khi nó ổn rồi đúng không Nhưng mà đây là
mình mình bảo là các bạn có thể làm được
ngay thôi nhưng mình đã từng nói các bạn
hạn chế ghi có dấu ở trong bên lập trình
từ ca về sau các bạn lập trình các bạn
sẽ hiểu
nghe tiếng Việt mình nó rất hơi bị trừu
tượng ấy thì em mình nhập có dấu rồi
thêm du khách nữa Vì Sao Chẳng Biết Ở
mình đặt tên cột như nào một lần này ra
là mình đến nó là theo kiểu theo quy tắc
và biệt lập trình thôi đúng không ạ
ví dụ là sổ bạn
trượt
lần 1 và qua môn lần hai gà tiếng Việt
Thành là nó bị kiểu nó hơi bị dài dài
dòng đoạn này tiếng Anh thì chắc ạ
mình nghĩa là sẽ có khách thể ngắn hơn
một tí
ở đó
anh gà trống dài nghỉ
tiếp
mình nghĩ là mình sẽ chữa câu
ở trên này trước đi câu trên này tôi ở 2
sao nhà thờ ra nó kiến thức mới nên mình
đánh hay sao thì ra coi ra dễ các bạn
trai rồi cao nó có thể ra được cái tra
thì nó là như thế này là ví dụ là ra sửa
các bạn tra SG server đúng không
khi sỏi hàm hàm và phương trình này
ghét
ghét lấy lấy độ dài lấy độ dài của chuỗi
gatlin học Sơ Trinh lấy độ dài của chuỗi
để chưa mà nó sẽ ra cái hàm này hả Mày
tên hàm lens Em viết tắt chị
A và các bạn sẽ ở đây sẽ là gì
anh kể tên không được phép ngắn hơn 2 ký
tự tất cả mình sẽ kiểm tra độ độ dài của
cái tên
Ế là là bao nhiêu ký tự tối chưa
xe tải thì các bạn sẽ là enter thấy bồ
này át Check tên được ạ
check độ dài tên đi
sau đó đi mình đây có một cái trách đúng
không là
nè của họ tên
phải lớn hơn
hay lớn tại lớn bằng hai nghĩa là tên sẽ
không được phép ngắn quá ngon
chạy thử nhé sẽ Đùa đúng không Các bạn
thấy chạy này không báo lỗi vì đơn giản
là tên của sinh viên nãy giờ đều lớn
bằng hai ký tự do sự bây giờ mình sẽ đi
Shop 1 bạn lỗi thì có bạn có thể xem
được là sửa lại đi sợ bạn tên là ao trở
lại phải nhập điểm vẫn bình thường không
ở đó thì được các bạn sẽ thấy nó bị lỗi
à à
à à anh
lấy kết quả từ có bề làm câu c á Cái này
chị các bạn chỉ là thùng xe lách thôi
giống như trong trường hợp này câu sao
hai phao này Thực ra là mình còn đang
định là hôm nay chưa trả lời câu này bởi
vì à câu này nó đúng là sao thật cái câu
này cốt là để cho những cái bạn mà học
rồi bạn ấy vào xem video của mình và
thấy kiến thức hàng dễ mà tao học hết
cái đúng này rồi thì thì đây là những
cái cầu dành cho những bạn đấy là để
biết được là kiến thức các bạn
bị hồng từ cái bên cơ ba cái này là một
câu
xe nâng cao nhưng là từ cơ bản chưa mạnh
nâng cao và từ cao siêu quá
à mình mình nói hơi bị nghe nó Cứ thỉnh
thoảng hơi bị mâu thuẫn một tí nha các
bạn
thì các bạn cũng dễ hình dung mà đúng
không
ở tại Tại sao ở đây mình nói cơ bản bởi
vì à Công này giống như bạn vừa hỏi cũng
rất là đúng lúc đó là nó kết hợp kết quả
từ hay câu Tại sao
bây giờ mình sẽ làm cái ở trong trò này
trước
anh kiếm thì sẵn trả lời được cái câu
này Đấy nó là như thế
em
có một bạn nữa cũng hỏi về cái vụ trận
tách họ tên thì tí mình trả lời nhé
Đợi mình mình trả lời có mày trước là ai
không cho đỡ bị lạc đề gì
ạ bây bây giờ mình để lấy được mỗi cái
này thì các bạn lấy được rồi đúng không
tìm chưa con này mình lấy được nghỉ mà
mình phải làm nhé lần 1 chưa qua đúng
không xưa nek sao form sinh viên đúng
không
Where điểm lần 1
nhỏ hơn ăn mà chưa qua mà nó không chưa
nhập điểm lần 2 tức là sao nghĩa là giả
sự là khi mà nhập in-shop bạn ấy vào rồi
đúng không mình à
Ừ mình mới chỉ nhập điểm là một bạn đấy
nghĩa ra xử lại chưa thi ạ Đúng chưa ra
xử thế nghĩa là bạn đấy điểm lần 2 vẫn
là trống đúng không em
điểm lần hay ít muốn
ở đó chạy thử nhé À thế à Mình mình chưa
nhập bạn sinh viên làm như thế đúng
không đây Mình sẽ thử nhập này Insert
into này
sinh viên này à họ tên điểm lần một việc
lớn hay đúng không Mình mình nghĩ mình
copy ở trên này nó nhanh hơn Đợi mình
chị
ừ ừ
em giả sử ở điểm là một người nam này để
lần 2 mình để ở trống này cô này bạn anh
tên là anh thế này chẳng
ở đó làm thử select này bạn sẽ ra thấy
cái bạn này cơm chưa
Ừ ok Bây giờ trả lời được câu trong
ngoặc rồi thì có tính là mùa sao không
đúng không
Thì ở đây hay sao ngon trả lời một câu
về cho nữa sao đúng không
Thì à
Tôi đếm Đếm số bạn cần phải thi lần 2
thì các bạn sẽ cao cao sao Thôi đã xong
đúng không
à à
ở đó thế là xong
ừ ừ
Ừ Ừ ở ngoài
à À không không không Cái này bạn bạn
vừa nói về cái vụ dùng cái trên để nó
check đấy Thực ra là nó cũng không đúng
lắm
Sao
lại vậy sao đây mình thử Xóa đi cho bạn
thì sẽ rõ này
à nếu nếu mà như thế thì nó sẽ ra là là
ba đúng không vì sao vì cái này lấy cả
những cái bạn à ngay từ lần 1 bạn ấy đã
qua rồi thế không đúng
em chỉ lấy những bạn điểm dưới 5 thôi và
điểm lần hai luôn thôi thì nó mới chuẩn
không Không dùng cái trách của cái trên
kia được Nó không đúng
3000 các bạn không nên dùng từ không nề
mà thay cho là chưa nhập điểm mình nói
về vụ luôn rồi mày nghỉ
các bạn này chắc là chưa xem cái buổi mà
hôm đấy mình nói với vũ
Không và chứ không là thức tỉnh mình sẽ
nói lại rồi nhé lùn
ừ ừ
em lại nói anh ấy đâu Tại mình sẽ lưu
lại đấy
ở đây đây đây là thí lại các bạn nha
ờ ờ trường hợp này trường hợp có giá trị
này ở trường hợp mình có người yêu này
đúng không
ở trường hợp không này đúng không là
trường hợp mà mình có nghĩa rồi nhưng
chia tay này chẳng gặp nun ở trường hợp
mà mình chưa từng có người yêu này
trường hợp and I find là trường hợp ở
Khi mà mình còn không biết vì yêu là gì
nữa trong đầu mình không định nghĩa
người yêu là gì luôn đấy thì cái trường
hợp này trường hợp mình chưa từng có
người yêu là trường hợp FA là Forever
Alone nghĩa là chưa từng có nhiều đúng
không Cũng giống như ở trong trường hợp
này là mình chưa từng nhập điểm đúng
không đáy còn trường hợp any file là
mình chưa từng
mình chưa từng thi luôn mình không còn
biết môn này môn thì em ạ mà trường hợp
không này là mình nhập điểm vào nhưng
nhập bằng không Đấy nó sẽ khác đúng
không nó khác với việc là bạn Nhập vào
và không Rồi Quý ốc nó là chưa nhập Thế
đã sai đúng không Tôi về bên lập trình
thì luôn mới lạ chưa chưa nhập về chưa
300 bị lạc chủ đề đâu nhé Có bạn vừa hỏi
là sao không nhập không thay vì nôn thì
mình trả lời em à ừ ừ
à à
Ừ đúng rồi bạn phát mẹ Trời đúng đó là
có điểm lần nào thì nên nhập lần lấy
luôn và bây giờ Giả sử có thêm điểm mới
nào ạ thì các bạn sẽ phải update đúng
không sự update ví dụ là sử update sinh
viên đúng không xét là là kiểu cập nhật
cho cục nào đúng không
điểm lần hai bằng ba thằng ăn Where mã
bằng gì đấy là lạ đấy đúng không Mình sẽ
cập nhật cho bạn mãn trí này là xử thế
thì bạn này sẽ được cập nhật thì nó mới
đúng
ừ ừ
à à
Anh ở trường hợp chuỗi dẫn đúng không ý
bạn ở trường hợp chuỗi rõ này đúng không
Bạn hỏi có ra cũng rất là hai cái chuỗi
rỗng hay là phone
hay là không
à hay là thậm chí ở Vì sao các bạn viết
về mảng thì nó sẽ là như thế này họ vì
sao các bạn biết về đối tượng này nó sẽ
như này tất cả những cái này đều tính là
sạc nó nó là giá trị Nhưng mà giờ chị
rỗng có điều tính ở giá trị dẫn
Ê bà nó sẽ đều tương tự nó lại MC là
rỗng mà đúng không đều là mt đã dẫn
và nó sẽ đều bằng không hết đều bằng
nhau hết sẽ đều bằng nhau
à
à Bạn vừa rồi hỏi thêm một câu cũng cũng
hay nữa
bây giờ để trả lời câu của bạn thì buổi
hôm nay mình sẽ học về hà màn đúng không
Nãy giờ Chữa bài tập là các bạn cũng
biết qua về cái hàm cao dồi rồi nhưng
bây giờ ra sửa nhé
cho
ví dụ là mình muốn đến muốn đến những
bạn
chị đã thi lần 2 chẳng ạ đúng không đã
thi lần 2 thì các bạn có phải là đến cao
sao form sinh viên Where điểm lần hai
đúng không
I eat slot nun đó thế này
thì các bạn sẽ không so sánh những kiểu
như này được bởi vì như mình đã nói thì
trong nun trong SQL thì không so sánh
bằng được các bạn sẽ phải It's not known
để lấy ra những người bạn đây mình mình
cứ bỏ cao đi nữa nhé
vì thế bạn sẽ lấy là những bạn mà đã xin
lần hai đúng không
Em thử sự chạy cái này trước này các bạn
sẽ thấy da có bạn có bạn anh và bảng
tuần hai này thì một lần 1 qua rồi đúng
không lần 2 thì
lần 2 thì không phải tí nữa thế này bây
giờ mình để mà mình chạy như này thì
mình sẽ chỉ lấy ra những bạn có thi lần
2 có điểm lần 2 chính xác có điểm là
chiều
Ừ thì biết rồi thay vì có bạn phải tốn
công như thế này thì các bạn chỉ việc
cao
điểm lần 2 như ai sẵn ạ ạ
anh chỉ có bạn sẽ ra những bạn
cho những bạn là điểm đến 20 new
Em thấy chưa
chị thay vì phải mình mình mình ghi lại
cho bạn dễ dùng nhé
ở bên chạy chạy từ này ra ba bạn Bạn ổn
chưa đúng không
tiếp theo nhé vì một đến đúng không đến
thì là cao gì chứ gì Đúng không
anh như này
anh cao sao bản chất nó gì nó cứ đếm hết
nó không quan tâm Cột nào nun hay các
thứ thì bây giờ rõ ràng là các bạn muốn
kiểm tra cột
kiểm tra cột thứ 2
a new nay không đúng không
địa
chỉ các bạn sẽ đếm ra tất cả những cái
sinh viên điểm lần 20 nhún là sóng như
thế này nghĩa là câu này sẽ bằng với câu
ở dưới như này cả hai đều trả về kết quả
bằng nhau tìm chưa
à à
Ừ nó các bạn sẽ thấy là
một là mình ghi rồi nha Mình có mất thêm
cuwar đúng không còn cao như này thì nó
sẽ tự động Loại bỏ cho các bạn những
trường hợp nào nên rồi nó chị đến những
thằng không nôn thôi thành ra là câu này
nó sẽ hai câu này nó bằng nhau
ở đây chơi
ở ngoài ra cái này còn thêm những cái gì
nữa không Không phải mỗi hàm đến đúng
không Mình có thể hạn dùng hàm các bạn
học Excel rồi Cái này bản chất là nó
mới bảo mình nó giờ tương tự giống như
Maxell Đó là các bạn hoàn toàn để dùng
hàm đến tổng này đến trung bình này thật
sự là bây giờ mình muốn lấy tổng điểm
lần 1 chẳng hạn thì là như thế này đúng
không nó sẽ ra là tổng điểm của tất cả
sinh viên sẽ là 20 điểm đúng không
có tổng điểm lần 2 nó sẽ nó sẽ bé hơn
một tí bởi vì là mình còn loại bỏ đi mà
còn loại bỏ có một vài bạn không đi lần
2 mà trả nợ thế đúng không tương tự là
mình muốn lấy điện trung bình hả Thì đó
sẽ là AVG là điểm trung bình sự là mình
lấy trung bình điểm lần 12 trung điểm
đặc biệt điểm lần 2 thì các bạn sẽ như
thế này thì chưa thế nhưng có một cái
hay ở đây nữa là lấy Trung bình thì ông
kiểu như này
đây cho bạn xem nhé
thì mình sẽ lách điểm lần 2 trước đi ừ
nếu các bạn thấy ở đây đang có tổng cộng
là bao nhiêu sinh viên
cho các bạn thấy có năm sinh viên đúng
không ạ
Ừ ok năm sinh viên đúng không Đây mình
lấy tổng điểm của nam mạng sinh viên này
nhá
ơi các bạn hãy năm 13 đúng không Đây đây
ờ ờ
v-app tổng điểm lần hai a
hỗ trợ hai cái một lúc được đấy
ảnh minh thư hỏi các bạn các bạn trả lời
nhanh nhé
ơi các bạn hãy đang có năm sinh viên
tổng điểm lần 2 là 13 Theo các bạn bây
giờ mình lấy trung bình mình lấy trung
bình điểm lần 2
Ừ thì nó xảy ra bằng mấy
thì nó sẽ là 13/5 hay là 13 chia cho 3
ừ ừ
thế
hả Theo các bạn thì ạ bây bây giờ mình
cho bạn xem lại phát nữa này đang có 5
bạn sinh viên mà đúng không Mà tổng là
13 đường chưa nhưng mà chỉ có 13 bạn có
điểm thôi đúng không Thì là 15 13 này sẽ
chữa cho năm để mà lấy ra trung bình hay
là 13 chị chia cho 3 bạn sinh viên thôi
hình ảnh
ở đây mình chạy thử thì mới biết đúng
không chạy thử thôi
a a di là đây à điện trung bình
lần 2 đúng không ạ
A chạy
Ừ nó
Ừ đúng rồi các bạn trả lời đúng rồi đó
là 13 chia cho 3 thôi không phải 13/5
đúng không Đấy đấy là hàm tác dụng của
thằng thằng B nasware và thực ra bị
Excel cũng sẽ Thế là các bạn không nên
dùng nó sẽ không dùng cái đếm Ví dụ ở
đây có thêm cái là
anh giống như vừa nãy
vì nó không phải dùng cái đến tất cả
sinh viên mà bản chất nó sẽ là đếm điểm
lần 2 để mở ra được Trung bình thì chưa
Nhớ nhớ mà mình vừa nói vụ là khi đến
điểm
đến số bạn thi lần 2 em ạ
xe tải mình cho bạn xem đúng
Ừ đấy thịt bản chất là có ở đây nha B
tất cả sinh viên đúng không Đây điểm tất
cả bạn sinh viên đúng không Thì đếm số
bạn khi lần hai à À nhầm nhà mình mình
bị ghi nhầm ghi nhầm
có tổng điểm bán hàng à
Ừ đấy thì có tổng điểm chuẩn 2013 nhưng
mà đếm số bạn khi là mỗi ba thôi thế nên
là nó sẽ dùng cái tổng này chia cho cả
này để ra này chứ nó không đến tất cả
sinh viên đúng không nó chỉ đến cho
những cái bạn làm có thi là lần hai thôi
Ừ ok các bạn hiểu là lá rồi em ạ thì à Ở
đây có bạn bảo muốn làm tròn số đúng
không thì giả sử Giả sử mình chưa biết
hàm làm tròn đúng không Thì mình lại
hướng dẫn các bạn cho Google này
thì ở đây là format khái niệm là các bạn
muốn
em chỉnh lại đây cái từ khóa thì các bạn
trao tra Google cho tiện này round ra và
làm tròn để chuyển đổi nhưng Ý Chí Minh
á mình mình dễ cho các bạn từ khóa để mà
các bạn biết tra lập trình các bạn muốn
hiển thị lại thay đổi lại cái hiển thị
thì các bạn sẽ có khái niệm mà format
hoặc là format
Ừ cái từ format đấy nó sẽ luôn là cấu
hình kiểu tinh chỉnh lại cái phần nào
hiển thị để trưa mình sẽ là format sờ
tiếp theo là gì mình muốn đổi mình mình
muốn đổi số mà pho mát năm bờ đấy SQL
Server cả đã xong
ở đây chưa đấy tương tự nó sẽ còn hàm
pho mát date này năm bờ này hay các thứ
cho các bạn
ở đó đó đó là cách kỹ năng chào Google
biết biết từ khóa tra được chưa Thì ở
đây nó còn thậm chí ở trạm nó còn theo
cả
ở có mát lại đến để mà ra được ngày
tháng năm theo kiểu là bên nước ngoài
cái thứ này đúng không ạ
khi format các thứ thử này
máy kẹp để xem nào
a
How to format number in SQL Server trong
bé đúng với này cái kiểu ngay sẽ làm
tròn hơn các thứ thứ
Bóng đèn ô
n11 là tương ứng với Có bao nhiêu số số
sau số thập phân thì chưa ạ
À hôm nay thầy hiệu trưởng mà đi chơi
với người yêu rồi đi chơi chung cùng
người yêu nên không có đây à
cô bạn kia hỏi một câu thở ra là câu này
cũng không ăn được các bạn lắm Bởi vì
liên quan bên lập chính đó là khi mình
cố thì mình xử lý ở bên
datapes rồi gửi cho ngôn ngữ văn bagn để
mà
Thế Hiển thị hay là ngôn ngữ Bắc em xử
lý đúng không khi
từ thực tế đó là dữ liệu như thế nào
luôn
anh luôn lên
gửi lại về cho ngôn ngữ lập trình ngôn
ngữ lập trình sẽ làm bài toán hiển thị
hay làm bài toán về tính toán hay cái gì
đó có dữ liệu như nào thì mình có thể
hoàn toàn là dữ liệu đầy chả mê cho ngôn
ngữ lập trình
Ừ mình chỉ mình chỉ cậu Where ví dụ là
sự cũng không cũng Tránh trường hợp Ví
dụ là kiểu bây giờ như thế này nhá
lấy tất cả bạn trượt môn được ạ đúng
không thì các bạn ạ
ẩm thực tế là các bạn có thể snack
sao form sinh viên như này thôi cũng
được lấy tất cả sinh miễn đấy tất cả
thông tin của sinh viên
sau đó thì ở gửi về cho ngôn ngữ lập
trình dùng ngôn ngữ lập trình sẽ tự động
duyệt xem bạn nói trượt bạn nào đỗ Nhưng
mà thế Thật ra Thành Quán lạ quá nặng
khi mà để trở về khi mà rõ ràng có thể
dùng que ở đây để mà lọc đúng không que
điểm
lần 1 nhỏ hơn 5 chỗ ngã ra xứ thế thì để
lọc bớt và trả mày để cho bên bên ngôn
ngữ lập trình xử lý nó nhẹ hơn nhưng có
một vài cái liên quan đến gặp vọng bài
toán format vừa rồi bạn ấy bảo thực tế
là eduard nó có hỗ trợ flash đầy nhưng
các bạn không cần nên làm pho mát ở bên
ashworth mà nên dùng ngôn ngữ lập trình
để mà làm mụ đấy bởi vì
anh Bởi vì giả sự vừa rồi các bạn pho
mát Nó là là Thành à
A11 ví dụ là kiểu thành số thập phân
kiểu dạng là
từ 1.000 trở nặng các thứ thế này đúng
không hay vân vân ngay đúng không Nhưng
mà đây là
ở đây là các bạn quyết thẳng luôn là
1000 Nếu mà giả sử là bây giờ đây tiền
em ạ đồ về nước ngoài thì tiền có thể
chấm Không không làm sao được Nhưng mà
với tiền của Việt Nam thì em ạ thì đồng
tiền của mình lại không có chấm Không
không bằng sau không có chấm gì cả đúng
không đồng tiền mình ở đồng tiền kiểu nó
tiền chẵn theo kiểu là nó không bị đè lẻ
ra đúng không Không bị lẻ phẩy phẩy phẩy
gì cả đúng không Thì nó lại thành sai
đúng chưa Chỉ cái này phải để cho ngôn
ngữ lập trình nó sẽ phải căn theo quốc
gia hay là ngôn ngữ Hải Vân Vân Vân để
và hiển thị cho nó chuẩn
Ừ cái thứ mà mình trả về kết quả cho
người dùng chỉ cần đúng thôi
em không kể buổi họp hôm nay thì chỉ đến
tạm dừng đến tặng đến bước ngày thôi mà
Thế nên là mình bởi nhảy sáng Bến Tre
chứ Đó là cao bạn Hôm nay mình dậy các
bạn về những hàm cơ bản mà đúng không và
chữa bài tập
em đi chưa Cái này chị chuyển giản là
những cái cơ bản ngay thôi
Ừ
cái này thử cái Ngoài ra có mình mình sẽ
nói thêm một cái nữa đó là thứ ra hôm
trước các bạn có nhớ vụ đã không trước
họ sẽ còn những cái hàm mà thời gian nó
không cần liên quan đến Cột nào cả
em không có liên quan cột ví dụ ra sự là
hàm lấy ngày tháng năm hiện tại chẳng
hạn nhớ nhớ vụ này không là ghét
chaeronea high school In Time em ạ
Apple Server này thì nó sẽ hàm kết date
này để lấy thời gian hiện tại C ghét
date này nó không cần liên quan đến bảng
ở luôn nó luôn trả về nó luôn trả về
thời gian hiện tạ
Em dậy chưa thời gian hiện tại này nó là
cấu hình trên trình máy các bạn máy bạn
bao nhiêu giờ nó sẽ bị bệnh như giờ chứ
không phải là theo quốc tế hay theo gì
cả à
ý thì cái Hàn này các bạn thấy em nó
chẳng Thật ra chẳng đi quan bạn nào đúng
không vừa rồi mình vừa chạy không cần
đến qua bạn nào hoặc giống như cái Hàn
Hôm trước mình có nói là Hà Mi chọn để
lấy 5 từ cái mốc thời gian từ một cái
chuỗi thời gian đó hoặc gà hầm ăn cả
đúng không thì các bạn sẽ thấy là trong
AK Wow này có rất nhiều hàm có sẵn mình
mình cứ gọi đến Mình cứ tra Google gọi
đến mà dùng thôi đúng không ạ
A và cái này còn lại tiếp tục nói thêm
một tí nữa ra sự thật sự đây nhé
I miss her neck Sao lại
form sinh viên này à
ở đây mình có
nhà mình có hai bạn Hai bạn cùng 3 điểm
đúng không
a a thuốc cho số bình thường in-shop một
bạn năm nữa đi cho cái cái ví dụ này nó
dễ hình dung hơn với các bạn nha à
vì lý do bạn Long nữa đi không quan tâm
vậy Bao nhiêu điểm nhé Để tên hai bạn
Long giống hệt nhau đi đi sớm này
à à điểm lần hai phải chống được ạ Đây
nó đang bảo lỗi
a snack lại này các bạn thấy có hai bạn
lắm đúng không điểm khác nhau mã xa nhau
đúng không Bơ giờ xử là mình sẽ Black
sao form sinh viên
a where
khi họ tên bằng Long chẳng hạn
à à
ở câu này là lấy tất cả mạnh thanh long
mà đúng không tiếp theo là ý mình muốn
đến tất cả các bạn
Tên long ở trong lớp này chẳng ạ thì
mình sẽ chạy ngay đúng không
Ừ thì xảy ra được có hai bạn tên long ở
trong những trong danh sách này đúng
không ạ
thế nhưng bây giờ mình lại muốn theo
kiểu như này
ý mình muốn ha điểm tên của tất cả các
bạn
à à
anh nói chung là tránh chung triệu thế
ý nghĩa Giả sử là trong danh sách mình
mình cho xem lại danh sách nhé
những hình ảnh cho các bạn xem lại danh
sách nhé các bạn thấy ở đây đang có sáu
bạn sinh viên đúng không Nhưng mà muốn
đếm tên của các bạn mà tránh bị trùng là
sử đây có hai bạn Long ngồi Nhưng mà
thực ra bản chất là đây là triệu mục tên
đúng không muốn lấy một đếm số tên ở
trong cái danh sách này thì đây một này
ha này 345 chỉ còn ăn bạn thôi à 55 cái
tên ôi đúng không Chẳng qua có sáu bạn
và 12 Bạn chụp tên đúng không Thì mới
như thế thì các bạn sẽ khái niệm là bài
xì dách cao họ tên hạ
trại này
thì các bạn thấy nó trả về là 6 cái gì
Sao bạn có tên
sáu bạn có tên đúng mà không sai đúng
không Nhưng giờ mình muốn đến tên Chánh
chung ấy thì mình sẽ khái niệm là
distance
I Miss Teen mà nó sẽ lọc trùng cho các
bạn về chưa rút lại được nhà mình không
lấy cặp vú bài này vội cái này luôn giản
hơn distin nó sẽ lập chung là các bạn về
chạy thử nhé
báo các bạn sẽ thấy nó trị trả về năm
thôi Tại sao một vì bên mình không cao
nữa thì chị sẽ Lady xin thôi thì có bạn
sẽ dễ hiểu hơn
đó sẽ chi trả về những cái tên như thế
này và Ừ nó lắc trùng hộ các bạn ấy chưa
thì các bạn thấy thực ra là nó có một tí
hay ở đây xem xem lại nhanh các bạn nhé
thế này
anh chạy một lượt các bạn sẽ dễ hình
dung này
Ừ cái trên cung và lấy họ tên này Cái
dưới này là lấy họ tên Lập trùng này
thế này đặt ý thì mình bắt Asiad cho các
bạn dễ hiểu à họ tên đã lọc trùng
và cái dẫn à
đếm họ tên
à à
Ở đây họ tên của tất cả sinh viên ok rồi
Ngon anh kể tên này đã lập trùng Các bạn
thấy có một điểm gì hay ở đây không so
với danh sách trên này ngoài việc nó lắp
chung đã
ừ ừ
à à
thì các bạn sẽ thấy da nó được sắp xếp
lại khéo đừng ngồi chuẩn rồi Hà pristine
này nó sẽ sắp xếp lại theo danh sách
theo thứ tự tăng dần đúng không trịa nên
trước mà đúng không đấy em một điểm rất
hay của nó nghĩa là nó nó
chính xác là nó phải sắp xếp lại để nó
so sánh với nhau cái này chắc là để hôm
từ hôm sau mình sẽ nói qua về cái vụ à
máy tính hoạt động thế nào có ý Trỗi để
nói các bạn về cái á các bạn trả mình
từng nói cái cái vụ này về sinh viên
mình và sinh viên mình nghe cái rất là
hư thú ra hào hứng hôm sau mình sẽ là
qua một tí việc hack nhé
ở Tuy nhiên mình không đi hack mình nhấn
mạnh lại rồi mình không biết hack mình
cũng mà chưa hack được cái gì bao giờ
nhưng mình có đọc cái bài blog đấy và
mình hiểu được thì cơ chế khách của nó
bởi vì À cái này là liên quan đến cách
máy tính
có cách cách máy tính nữa kiểu hoạt động
với chuỗi như thế nào
Vì thế nên là nó vẫn là kiến thức và các
bạn hoàn toàn đi học được nghĩa là không
và các bạn không áp dụng được ở đâu đâu
chứ không phải học tấn có về phòng thủ
luôn cái này là cái này chẳng qua là
mình biết cơ chế hoạt động của máy tính
rồi thì nên là mình đọc cái bà đấy mình
nó toàn hiệu và người ta lợi dụng cái cơ
chế đấy để mà hack chưa
Ừ cái này nó là các bạn Thể tra qua đọc
qua trước được sợ các bạn đọc lại thấy
mình giảng không hay bằng bài 10 lúc đấy
nó là ờ
ừ à Nó nó không có rất tín ở hack đâu đó
là ở
Ừ tự nhiên mình quên mất à
à à
cô Kim Skills time i
cho mình
anh đợi mình tìm lại tên đã gửi mình bé
một kỹ thuật khách liên quan đến đo đo
thời gian
Anh ở trên a palak ngon palak bình
thường hay mình mình Thầy trên này là
cái kênh Block kìa ít người biết kênh
này và Block trên này Thực ra là ra chất
lượng nhưng mà ít người biết đến
thì các bạn hoàn toàn để đọc cái trên
cái này mình có lưu ở trên cái này mình
quên quên mất cái tên của nó thông cảm
Đợi mình cứ vào lại xem có kịp không
Ừ nếu chỉ sắp xếp không lọc chồng á Sắp
xếp thì các bạn từ khóa sẽ sót đúng
không xót
và ở trong ở bên lập trình a Bernabeu sẽ
là allby như thế này và các bạn sẽ chỉ
cần order brides server ạ
ở đây thì các bạn sẽ ra cả như thế này
thì các bạn sẽ order Bike sau đó Thị Ái
C hoặc
bps2c thì sẽ là thứ tự thứ tự tăng dần
còn đế sẽ giảm dần ở trong trường hợp
này các bạn muốn lấy à
à mình mình hơi bị lạc mềm tính mình nha
em buổi sau mình sẽ nói qua gỗ hack kia
mà chắc là buổi sao mình nói
thì các bạn và có thể lấy họ tên như này
và mình sẽ order Bike họ tên
Em hãy Xe chở nặng như thế này thì mình
sẽ lấy được tên được sắp xếp
nhưng cái này là nhược điểm Hồi trước
mình từng làm cái này và nó bị lỗi phải
đến mình cay với anh cái này nói vào nhà
thôi đấy Mình cứ mình hơi bị trẻ trâu và
tô Seek một tí mình cứ Định chửi thằng
sinh viên của mình về học sinh tên một
thằng sinh viên mình làm cho mình bị lỗi
em bị lỗi cái cốt cái cốt để ra cốc hiển
thị ở danh sách sinh viên ở trong lớp
Ê thằng sinh viên đẩy nó có tên là đ
ừ ừ
à Thằng ấy nó khiến cho mình bị lỗi cốt
Tại sao bởi vì cái chữ đờ của nó tên tên
tên là có cái đồ đúng không
em chưa
ờ ờ Vậy sao mình có nhận ra đó là chữ
đầu này có trong bảng chữ cái Latinh hóa
tình thì phải hai Unicode đấy
Vì thế nên nó không phải là nó không
phải là từ
vì nó không phải từ Unicode
Vì thế nên là nó khiến cho tên của thằng
này nó tự nhiên có dấu
Xin lỗi mình in ra bảng
bảng danh sách sinh viên tên tên tiếng
Ngay Nghĩa loại bỏ tất cả các dầu đi
riêng hoặc đức này Có dấu này ra lỗi
và đương nhiên là Đạt hay là cái nói
chung là Đạt Đức hay là bằng động gì đấy
nó có chữ đời mà nó ngon hãy ra lỗi đi
a a không sao Mình có chửi ai đấy đâu
mình đang nói là mình chửi thằng sinh
viên
nhờ yên tâm mình vẫn rất quý nó và nó
cũng
em yêu thương mình lắm
ở đây nhưng mà cái này là một cái trường
hợp mà Hi chị iu mình vì sao mình mò
được tự nhiên chứ đồ này nó thì mình
cách cách sửa thì mình đánh phải riêng
thủ công hàng ngày thì mình sẽ về đổi
những bạn nào có tên là đồ thì mình phải
đổi thành đỡ thôi đấy nhưng mà tự nhiên
mình đang chạy ngon lành là đội hết tên
từ
unicoat sang à
xe taxi là đổi hết Nói chung là đội hết
có có dấu thành không dấu có đúng không
những Riêng thằng này tự nhiên Thằng này
nó nó có tồn tại ở bên bản AC gì lại
thành nhờ mình phải đổi thủ công đầu
lạnh đầu như thế này
à mà đã thấy con cay hơn đó là khi mà
sắp xếp tên theo tên theo others ba như
thế này đúng không Thằng đến Đức nó lên
trên cùng của danh sách bởi vì đấy là
kiểu nó từ có dấu hấp từ nói chung là từ
có nghĩa này là không
anh cứ tên Đức Hải tên Đạt là Lê hết
trên đầu của danh sách trên và chữa luôn
khi bạn nghe thấy vũ khí gì không ạ
ạ sau đó đi về sau mình còn biết được là
khái niệm order bang này nó không phải
nó còn phải theo cả ngôn ngữ nữa nó là
các bạn phải tra theo ngôn ngữ sắp xếp
theo ngôn ngữ đã Bởi vì giờ sự là bây
giờ nếu mà các bạn Nếu mà sắp xếp nhà
nhé Nếu là sử tên là áng hạ khi nó nó sẽ
sung cuối là lạ bởi vì nó là A như là nó
có dấu unicorn nên nó sẽ để xuống cuối
chứ nó không còn ở trên cùng đâu chưa
mình thử Insert ở bên bên mái queo thì
mình mình bị thế không biết ở bên này có
bị không đem thử mình in-shop thiệu cho
rõ nhé á
em chạy lại
anh ở đây đây đây mày mày bên này không
bị
à à bên này thứ cũng bị ảnh hưởng này
đúng không Nếu mà nhìn này
Nếu các bạn muốn sắp xếp theo đúng mỗi
cái chữ cái đầu nó khác Còn cái này là
cái này lại cái không sợ không hôm sau
Mình định nói này Cái liên quan đến việc
So sánh chỗ này đúng không
ừ ừ
Ừ cái này So sánh chuỗi cái chỗ này dài
ăn chỗ này nên chỗ này sẽ đứng sau chỗ
em đứng trước cho rõ ràng Các bạn thấy
chữ á phải nằm chữa 222 phải nằm cạnh
nhau đúng không Đấy thấy thấy tên có dầu
sẽ sinh em bất kỳ à mình phải sắp xếp
theo
ở chèo ngôn ngữ với dỗ theo Vietnamese
này các thứ thứ khi nào mới sắp sẽ chuẩn
Ừ Đấy mình nói qua bài ví dụ thể cho bạn
hiểu đúng không Buổi sau thì mình sẽ
có thể thao hôm nay mình chưa nói được
cái về bên Goodbye và
Ừ
rồi có bạn nhắc thì order order vai này
hay là đi Mít đã có offset cho buổi sau
mình sẽ phải nói qua mình mấy cái này
trước trước khi sang phoneky là hôm nay
được ra cũng hơi nhiều thời gian
anh mất hơi nhiều thời gian cho mấy vụ
này Nhưng mày nghĩ mình nghĩa hôm nay
kiến thức thế này cũng tầm tầm thì các
bạn học đúng không các bạn sẽ không bị
quá ta thì buổi sau mình sẽ lại dạy tiếp
cái này cái này nó cũng dài đấy Cái này
giờ dài luôn mất cả một buổi khó ngoại
cho người bị buổi sau nữa đi khóa ngoại
là là cái thứ ca nó khá là lằng nhằng
phải sau tất cả đã
ở bên mình trả lời cái câu của bạn vừa
nãy bạn thấy hỏi bạn vĩnh viễn thì phải
bẻ hỏi là họ tên đúng không bạn một tách
cái họ ra vào tên ra để mà trách mỗi cái
độ dài của tên thôi chẳng hạn thì thì
bản chất là bạn bạn phải dụng là chủ
nghĩa Long này chẳng hạn thi tên chỉ
check mỗi thằng mỗi cái bên Long ấy thì
nhớ bạn vừa nãy có nói sắp sửa Trinh
đúng không là cắt chuỗi thì các bạn sẽ
tra Google khái niệm là sắp sửa Trinh
cắt chỗ này SQL Server này đó sẽ cắt chỗ
ấy từ đâu đến đâu cho các bạn ăn những
thức ăn thế này vẫn chưa đủ thực ra thế
này vẫn chưa đủ là thực ra thế này có
sai Vì sao cắt chỗ này nó chỉ treo độ
dài ký tự thôi
Ừ đúng rồi bạn kia phải nói là sắp sửa
trình Index nó mới chuẩn
anh bay từ khóa thì các bạn tra thôi Sắp
chương trình Iraq là nó sẽ à
sẽ cắt chuối theo à
à à thả không đúng lắm để mình tra lại
xem nhé
Em sắp ở Explorer sinh Nhật Bản
à à
ở đây đây rồi mà
Ừ cái khái niệm là để mặc các các bạn
cắt heo một cái ký tự nào đó như thế này
thì nó sẽ khác với việc cắt chữa bình
thường thì các bạn sẽ về tra Google là
Explorer trinh như thế này để
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ để mà các bạn sẽ cắt chuối nhau dầu
cách sau đó thì các bạn chỉ lấy cái
thằng cuối cùng sau dấu cách thì nó lấy
được tên tôi chưa đó trả lời hết câu hỏi
các bạn rồi Xuka video nó sắp thành hai
tiếng thôi xin lỗi các bạn nhờ mình bơ
mình sẽ trả lời nhanh có các bạn hỏi
mình về cái vụ mà ờ ờ
khi đi thực tập như thế nào chia sẻ về
câu chuyện đi đi đi thực tập ra là gì
Ừ mình đầu tiên là mình
35 nhất của mình là đầu tiên là chồng
mình Mình không học đại học chính quy
Ừ
mình học cao đẳng cao đẳng nghề kiểu cực
thế nên thành ra là mình chỉ cần học 2
năm là mình có thể đi thực tập được rồi
năm nhất của bọn mình thì thì bọn mình
học mấy môn kiểu mấy môn đại cương thôi
vì môn kiểu bên đại học chính quy cũng
có học còn à
à còn 52 của mình thì mình mới học sang
bên chuyên ngành 52 mình làm tận hai cái
đó hai cái sản phẩm trước khi đi thực
tập thì nên là mình cũng có thí nghiệm
một chút theo chiều mình dạy cho thế
mình thấy hay phết kiểu áp dụng thực về
luôn áp dụng thẳng và bài tập luôn chứ
thi cử nó chẳng quan trọng nữa bên mình
không quan trọng thi làm đâu các bạn đi
tư đi thực tập rồi để oto10 nói thẳng
như thế các bạn sẽ không Bởi vì học
trường Ê mà với các bạn để có cái nghề
mà đúng không nên là các thầy cô không
làm khó các bạn các bạn Có nghề rồi
chẳng ai làm khó cả
Ừ Anh nghe là mình mình năm 52 Mình học
ở
Ừ mình học làm xong để đồ ăn hay lắm làm
một cái sản phẩm cũng tương đối lớn sau
đó khi mình xin đi được tập
anh đi phỏng vấn như mình đã từng kể
việc mình may mắn đó là
ạ Mình chẳng cần phải phỏng vấn lắm rồi
cái ngành nghề này kiểu người ta còn
tuyển luôn ý và đương nhiên là cũng có
một buổi phỏng vấn Thực ra người ta cũng
chị hỏi mức tương đối
hoặc là mình cảm thấy là mình trả lời
được với Thế Thành ra họ cho qua bởi vì
à mình Mình thấy nhiều bạn phỏng vấn
xong các bạn sẽ kiểu à Em cứ em cứ về đi
mình sẽ thông báo sau các thứ thứ sau đó
hư mất hút còn mình thì toàn kiểu em
ngồi làm luôn tại đây được không hoa
kiểu mai đi làm luôn được không vân vân
là kiểu thế
em thì không ăn mời đâu mình chẳng qua
lại gọi nha mình à
à mình làm Chính vì cái sản phẩm đồ ăn
hay của mình khá là tương đối ổn em
thành ra là có cái khoe cũng như là có
người biết đến mình bởi vì hồi hồi 52
mình làm cũng là mình khối đấy Mình mới
vào nhóm như tinh công ty sau đó thì
mình ạ mình bảo mình bị choáng ngợp Bình
mình ngưỡng mộ vì những anh rất công
nghệ trong này rất là giỏi đấy Thành A
mình cũng không hỏi anh ấy làm tôn
Facebook các thứ đúng không Thế thì mình
tìm hiểu về mảnh tôn Facebook Vì thế nên
là mình có cái thứ để khoe khi phỏng vấn
thành ra họ cảm thấy là Ừ trong này cũng
có đam mê thì ra là phỏng vấn cũng tương
đối dễ dàng người bạn có hỏi mình chút
về thuật toán mình cũng trả lời một cách
kiểu cũng không biết vì lắm đấy nhưng mà
vẫn phỏng vấn được thôi à
cho nên là các bạn à muốn người ta Người
ngoài nhìn vào mình đúng không họ Đôi
khi họ không biết được là bạn tài giỏi
đến đâu đúng không Thì bạn phải phải
chứng minh cho họ bằng một cái sản phẩm
thực tế gì đó chứ không để chứng minh
bằng mồm được những cái hạn chế khi mà
đi phỏng vấn đó là hạn chế nói mấy câu
là kiểu đó Em chỉ biết mỗi kiến thức
trên lớp
Anh thấy em dại như là anh chỉ biết mỗi
thế
ở Hà
anh hoặc là
anh hoặc là từng từng có đứa bạn của
mình đi phỏng vấn và bị đuổi về nói kể
lại cho mình buổi phỏng vấn nó nó học
trên đảo chính quy nhá 53 nó bắt đầu mới
học viên chuyên ngành thì ạ Bạn thì gần
như a25 đầu nó là đi làm với cái kiểu
lao động chân tay kiểu các thứ kiểu bồi
bàn thứ đúng không hoa cà làm siêu thị
đúng không cái thì lúc mà nó lúc mà nó
54 là đi thực tập đấy Xong rồi người ta
hỏi nó nó có kinh nghiệm gì chưa Họ đã
làm gì chưa ấy thì nó bảo là
anh em có 2 năm kinh nghiệm làm 13
nó họ nói đúng rồi đấy luôn ạ Và cuối
cùng với kết quả là gì
Ừ thôi em quay lại làm bồi bàn tiếp đi
em ạ Cứ thế em chỉ là kiểu các bạn học
gửi tiếng Anh này thì các bạn nên kiểu
có không hẳn là có thí nghiệm về ngày
này Bây giờ mới đi được tập mà thì mới
có kinh nghiệm đúng không Nhưng mà các
bạn nên dành thời gian cho cái này này
chứ không phải là các bạn khoe việc cả
các bạn có kinh nghiệm mình khác nó chả
đi ngoan này cả đúng không ạ
anh đúng không Bây giờ bạn khoảng vấn và
bạn hỏi cái thằng mà kiểu có có câu trả
lời như thế thì bạn muốn chuyện đó hẹ
bảo đã thay có nhiều kinh nghiệm thế
chắc là nó giỏi cái gì ấy không không
chỉ khán giả là nó nó dành thời gian quá
nhiều thứ mà không không liên quan đúng
không trứng to có thể nó không đam mê và
cái ngày này thành dành thời gian như
thế thành ra là nó bị
anh đấy Đấy là những câu mà bạn không
ngờ nên nói khi mà đi phỏng vấn mình
không biết có ai từng nói các bạn những
điều đấy chưa ạ
em thậm chí ở khi nào mình sẽ chia sẻ
các bạn cách viết CV của mình Thứ CV
mình cũng không hoàn đẹp lắm Mình cũng
không giỏi Văn nó làm hai vân vân mình
không phải nhà Tuyển dụng nên là thực sự
mình không biết đánh giá về cái CP mình
như thế nào nhưng mà mình cũng mình là
thầy mà đúng không Mình cũng có
mình cũng trải qua nhiều về mấy cái vụ
CV nó đều như là như nào rồi mình chỉ
biết đều anh nhá Mình không biết chị là
như nào thì mình sẽ nói qua về các bạn
về cách viết CV không phải bên mỗi ngành
công nghiệp in nhé Thì sẽ nói qua cách
viết CP chung để bạn biết được là về CV
nó ổn
ý là tránh nên tránh những cái gì đấy
Cái đấy thì mình biết đủ
anh đi
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ mình đi thực tập ở mình là à Đấy lại
nhắc về cái vụ ạ
Anh bình thường Ai khuyên sinh viên của
mình khuyên một chuyện thôi Bọn nó toàn
theo ngẫu hứng bọn nó toàn kiểu an
toàn bộ ngoại tay hơi buồn đó là
mình toàn khi sinh viên mình là với dân
công nghệ thông tin thì các bạn nên
Em đừng có nên ham vào mấy cái công ty
lớn khi mà mới đi thực tập Ừ thì nó có
rất nhiều cái tốt có tiền hình là họ có
hẳn một phòng ban để mà chuyên đào tạo
các bạn với họ chưa thường người mà họ
có đầy đủ nhân sự để mà đào tạo các bạn
nhưng
khi họ không cho các bạn được động vào
những cái những cái kiểu tất cả mọi cái
để các bạn học hỏi các bạn sẽ chỉ được
làm một phần một rất là bé ở trong một
cái tính năng bé các sự thứ các bạn sẽ
không học họ được nhiều
Ừ Thì bài toán thực lại đây là gì thì
các bạn nên phải tìm những công ty bé
thậm chí những công ty sợ lắm
anh biết công ty đấy nó sẽ gọi ưu và
nhược Nghe công ty bé thì các bạn sẽ học
hỏi được rất nhiều từ những người còn là
Xét luôn Thậm chí học hỏi trực tiếp được
xếp vào các bạn bởi vì
các phòng ban ít người mà đúng không thì
các bạn sẽ tiếp xúc với tất cả mọi người
và tiếp xúc với cả sếp và học hỏi từ sẽ
rất nhiều ạ
à Thằng A các bạn được làm rất nhiều thứ
và học rất nhiều thứ đúng rồi
Các bạn vào vào công ty lớn thì các bạn
sẽ gần như là con kiến ăn đấy họ chẳng
quan tâm các bạn
thì các bạn không được động mà cái gì
Các bạn cũng không hỏi đứa ít và các bạn
thể bị đuổi bất cứ lúc nào cũng vì các
bạn bé tí còn ở trong công ty nhỏ thì
các bạn sẽ có tấm ảnh thuộc các bạn cảm
thấy mình quan trọng và các bạn sẽ
tự hào hứng hơn
Ê bà cái quan trọng mình vẫn đang nhấn
mạnh đó là các bạn học hỏi được xếp
khi sếp càng giỏi thì công ty nhỏ đầy nó
mới càng tồn tại được các bạn học hỏi
tôi rất nhiều xếp hồi đi thực tập đầy
mình bị bóc lột sức lao động Thái nhiều
khẳng định luôn bởi vì nửa năm liền
mình làm 6 tháng đúng không Mỗi tháng
lực phụ cấp nhựa trợ cấp cho mình chỉ
500.000 về sau mãi mình mới tăng lên
được một triệu cho dù mình làm fulltime
FPT Software nó một trong những cái lớn
rồi đấy Cái cái chín cái mình đang nói
đó FPT sofware tuyển thực tập nhiều vãi
xong rồi Kiểu sinh viên mình đến một
Đống Đa sinh viên gọi rủ nhau đi thực
tập ở chỗ đấy Xong rồi bọn nó rủ nhau
ngồi chơi game luôn ở chỗ đấy mình nói
thế không phải em Chị nói xấu ở chỗ đấy
nha chỗ đây đào tạo vẫn rất tốt Nhưng ý
mình ạ
Ừ Nó kiểu nó bị sẹo Hạnh Seo thành phong
trào Anh thành nhà nó hơi bị sai sai
thì
ở Trung Hoa cái cung cái mình đã nói dở
đó là mình thực tập 6 tháng ở đấy trợ
cấp 500 sâu vì sao làm fulltime lên được
mỗi một triệu một tháng mà trong người
đó Tin nhắn có mất sự 600.000 rồi nghĩa
là bốn bốn trăm nghìn tiền trợ cấp xăng
xe mỗi hãng kiểu thế
anh Na
Anh thành ra là kiểu à
Ừ nhưng mà các bạn thời đầu đi thực tập
cái ngày này lượng thấp kinh khủng các
thứ thứ theo tất cả anh khám vì về cơ
bản thì lúc đầu các bạn có làm được cái
gì đâu các bạn sẽ phải gần như là bỏ
thời gian ra vào người ta phải bỏ thời
gian ra để dạy các bạn trên gọi là đào
tạo trên minh các bạn đúng không Đúng
rồi
Ẩm Thực ra là gần như là các bạn Thế cần
gì đi học hơn đi học lại từ đầu ấy các
bạn không trả tiền người ta người ta đã
tạo mình đi thôi ngon
ở trường ca đấy là một cái mà đó là rất
nhiều
nơi phỏng vấn nó muốn tìm xem bạn có đủ
à à có đủ năng lực kết hợp với đủ kiên
nhẫn để mà ở lại với họ hay không Họ sợ
rất nhiều công ty sợ đào tạo các bạn
xong các bạn lại nhận việc các bạn lại
bỏ công ty Thế các bạn cũng phải thể
hiện mình ạ
tâm huyết với công ty cũng nhờ sẽ gần mà
công ty lâu dài các kiểu nữa
ở Như Nói chung là mình học ở đấy học
hỏi được rất nhiều nên mình mới trụ lại
như dẫn 6 tháng như thế cho đến khi mình
cảm thấy mình
khi tổn nồi không học hỏi thêm gì nữa Và
họ cũng không
em không có đi tăng lương cho mình bởi
vì à Nó họ nói công ty áp họ cũng cần
tiền cũng chưa ra mắt sản phẩm nhưng mà
họ cậy là mình chưa Còn làm phi nghiệm
mình cần năm kinh nghiệm nên họ bóc lột
xưa động mình khá nhiều mình làm mình
làm hẳn vào cái chính rồi nhé chứ cũng
mình không còn gọi là kẹo không làm được
gì nhé mình làm được rồi hả Nói nhưng mà
họ nói cái câu là đợi khi nào mà em làm
như nhân viên à nhân viên bình thường
của bên anh thì anh sẽ trả lương em cái
thứ thứ nhân viên bình thường bên công
ty đấy công ty đang có hội đấy như có 6
người thôi xong rồi lập trình Ừ thì à
Toàn mấy anh hơn 10 năm kinh nghiệm rồi
gửi ở mình bảo làm nhưng mà làm như mấy
anh kia
Anh hiểu nghe Huế thấy gấu nó hết hi
vọng thôi Tôi bỏ rồi đúng không đi
Ừ nhưng mà mình chỉ nên bỏ Khi mà mình
cảm thấy la minh hết khứ để mà học hỏi
thôi Còn thời gian đầu mình hỏi chấp
nhận làm không công như thế coi như em
mình đi học thôi mà có như mình đi học
thôi vì không phải trả tiền anh kiêu thế
Ê bà mai mà mình cũng 52 đi thực tập
nên là mình đến 53 mình đã có rất nhiều
kinh nghiệm rồi so với bạn không nữa
à à à à
ở những công ty nào đào tạo lại cho mình
được không ạ Cái
Ừ cái này là mình cũng không hề biết
được rất nhiều công ty sẵn sàng nó nó
hiểu là mình chưa năm kinh nghiệm nó nó
phải ghi rõ thế quan trọng ấy đó là các
bạn để khi mà người ta tuyển đấy Cái ta
sẽ ghi rõ là có nhận thức nhận thực tập
201 khi nhận được tạo ra sản xác định ở
họ sẽ sẵn sàng đào tạo các bạn nhưng mà
Đương nhiên ạ tùy từng công ty nó sẽ hỏi
những cái câu là nó liên quan đến có thể
thuật toán cái gì đó đây mà lọc trước
các bạn là có đam mê hay là có tư duy
không vì nhiều công ty nó cũng hơi bị
lười tí đó là nó cứ tuyển những ông có
sẵn tư duy rồi sau đó thì vứt sư cho ông
ấy ông mới kể quyền tài liệu hay mà cái
link tài liệu để các bạn tự học công ty
công ty vừa uống rượu vừa rồi mình nói
Thời Gian Lúc đầu định thế đấy làm thế
với mình mà
Ừ nhưng mà nhưng mà mình lại gặp kể anh
mà không Hôm trước mình từng nói với anh
thầy của mình anh mà làm ra cái trang
phim Bất Hủ ấy anh đấy á kiến nhận nói
mình hỏi cái gì anh cũng trả lời và anh
đấy không đảm bảo cho mình để mình nói
mình may mắn là như thế bởi vì à chứ
không phải ai cũng rảnh rỗi thời gian để
mà dậy các bạn như thế đâu Đúng không
các bạn vẫn sẽ khả năng tự học các bạn
phải rất lớn đại học mặt chất nó là tự
học
Ừ nó đại mà mặt chất nó tự học tính cả
thầy cô dạy trên lớp các bạn cũng sẽ chủ
yếu cho các bạn tự học thôi mình dạy
nghề Thực ra Vẫn còn hơi bị à hơi bị
theo phong cách Hồi trước mình đi dạy ở
trường đoạn Cao đẳng nghề của mình đó là
vừa dạy vừa dỗ kết hợp với việc là dậy
từng vị từng tí một chứ đại học chính
quy thì các bạn sẽ được dậy một cách
gian chạy và và nó không kiểu từng tí
một như thế này không ạ
cho nên các bạn nhiều bạn sẽ thấy kẹo
ngọt khác với cách bạn được học trên
trưởng nên có thể các bạn sẽ thấy hoa
Hưng nhưng mà nó sẽ bị nhược điểm đó là
các bạn khả năng tự học các bạn sẽ bị
kém ly có bạn bị thụt
Vì thế nên là các bạn cũng nên cách để
mà các bạn hạn chế bị thụ động đó là các
bạn phải hỏi nhiều lên phải gọi liên tục
rồi mình từng làm các bạn phải hỏi phải
mò phải thắc mắc liên tục thì các bạn
hãy hạn chế bị thụ động
ừ ừ
ở đồng hồ Biên đại học chính quy hiện
rất nhiều lý thuyết để mà các bạn nắm
chắc về cái cơ bản còn bây giờ mình đang
dạy ở dễ thực hành để mà các bạn từ từ
thực hành các bạn sẽ hình dung được à À
nó là như thế nào nhưng mà lý thuyết các
bạn không nắm chắc thì các bạn vì sao
lại không biết chuyên sâu vào như thế
nào Ví dụ Giả sử với đó mình cứ biết mỗi
là chú ấy à thì dùng dùng cái cái này
các thứ thứ vì sau Các bạn không hiểu
bạn chất chỗ là gì ạ
ở mấy trang tìm việc như lycan
mình chuẩn bị phát âm đúng hay sai nữa
like annd này có phù hợp để thực tập
không ạ Có rất nhiều trang mình thấy
được các bạn nên hạn chế nên cái trang
ví dụ là Trang cái này vào nó hơi bị
nhạy cảm với động hơi nhiều ông lớn ông
ấy mắng mình nó là chung mà những cái
Trang mà tìm việc IV các lượng tử tìm
thấy được ra à
tỷ tùy mình không bao tìm trên mấy cái
Trang đấy Đúng rồi mình tìm cả trên lên
cân hay cái gì đó hơn
Anh thường mày công ty lớn thường ai
đang ở trên đấy hơn là và cũng còn như
tuyển dụng trên đấy hơn
ở top sibia
a ghi mình có biết mình cái trang kiểu
kia nhưng mà mình thấy thật ra là nó cứ
bị sao ấy thì người dùng từ bị xác không
kiểu thấy trên đấy nó cứ bị bị đại trà
Anh thành ra mình không tìm mấy việc
chưa chán đấy cả
à à
anh Liệt kê một số trang mình hay tìm
kiếm ý bạn ở Tìm kiếm công việc đó bởi
vì mình không tìm kiếm công việc gì cả
công việc nó cứ kiểu nó cứ bị tự đến ví
dụ là mình mới nghỉ dậy trước khi mình
nghỉ zậy
A Gọi nhà ở hồi mình đi được tập hồi 6
tháng kia đúng không
26 tháng 7 thì lúc mà mình ăn thực tập
đấy thì thầy của mình mời cái dạy ở
trường sau đó thì khi mình đang dạy ở
trường này gần đây Anh Tuấn mời làm ở
công ty anh ấy mới về thành ra mình kiểu
không đi tìm cái gì cả mà đã cả bây giờ
gần đây cũng có nhiều hl cũng nhắn tin
cho mình hỏi là họ tuyển tiền mình thành
ra là
Ừ mình không tìm kiếm gì cả nếu mà mình
cũng hỏi lại mấy người đấy mình mình rất
khỏi lại 10h ở đấy Đó là thứ nhất là bạn
thì mình qua đâu để mình biết được là
chị đã mình nên cải thiện cái Trang đấy
ví dụ Họ tìm có ít thấp mà có rican nhận
lại nên mình cải thiện lại cái trang này
trong thực tế không tí không người ta
nhìn vào đỡ đánh giá
tất cả là Cho
mình hỏi luôn cả họ là họ gửi cho mình
cái bản yêu cầu để mình mình xem lại về
việc xem lại bản thân mình xem là mình
cần phải cải thiện điều gì đó giữa họ họ
gửi mình xong rồi thấy mình cần phải học
thêm cái gì cần bao nhiêu năm kín đĩa
VCD Trang Hạ
à à
em à Thật hội sửa chữa mình cũng nghĩ
việc là nhưng mà Đấy con người của mình
và con người bị hướng ngoại nên mình mới
làm nổi bật trên trang cá nhân mình có
rất nhiều người mình thấy rất là giỏi
thế mà trên get hấp của họ hay ạ những
cái họ cũng đăng lên nhóm vì anh không
đăng lên nhóm utut mình Ai nhóm đi tim
committee được rất có rất nhiều người
giỏi nhé họ không đăng lên thì ta chẳng
ai biết đến học cả nhờ họ sửa rất là rồi
khi
họ bị hướng nội mà Thế nên là thế nên là
HR cái ngành Công nghệ thông tin này
không nhận tìm việc our team nhân tài
khóa ấy chị kiểu thông qua người quen là
nhiều hơn đấy
à à
à
mình để ga bây giờ mình bên công ty mình
đang thiếu người này mình hi vọng mình
hôm trước mình cũng nói lại với anh Tuấn
nó biết đâu mình Hi vọng ạ Mình đào tạo
được một vài bạn giỏi sau đó thì bạn đấy
lại có hứng thú về làm cùng công ty mình
tốt quá vậy công ty mình đang thiếu
người phải chưa ạ
Ừ mình đang làm mà bắt em mình à Mình
không giỏi về bên giao diện lắm
Chú Chó Tia mình đã từng hướng đến lạ là
mà
làm kiểu cổ đắp mà laser là quản lý phần
mềm liên quan đến việc là hướng đến trải
nghiệm người dùng Nhưng mà thực tế là
mình kém về thẩm mỹ phải ra mình không
làm ăn được
Ừ ok Nói chung là buổi hôm nay thứ dài
và mình phải đi lấy đồ đấy này tạm chào
các bạn nhé
thì kệ
à à